[Musique]
Alin Damasio, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Euh, est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ?
Bah, Alain Damasio, j'aime bien dire
écrivain de science-fiction tout
simplement. Même si j'ai fait du
scénario, même si j'ai fait des des
fictions radiophoniques, même si j'ai
fait du jeux vidéo, même si j'ai fait du
théâtre, ça reste le cœur de ce que je
fais, c'est écrivain de science-fiction.
Chanteur un peu maintenant, non ?
Ah, maintenant je dis plutôt parleur
parce que le chant, je suis incapable de
chanter vraiment. Mais euh ouais,
j'adore poser ma voix en tout cas sur
les textes et les porter comme ça en
musique. Ouais, ça c'est
Julien Sange qui se fait serrer
aujourd'hui.
Ouais.
Vous avez vu ça ?
Non, j'ai pas vu. Non. Qu'est-ce que
vous pensez le fait que Julien se fasse
serrer par la police ? Ah mais Julin
c'est pour moi c'est comme Snowden,
c'est c'est
une tragédie parce que voilà, c'est des
lanceurs d'alerte absolument euh
décisifs quoi, qui devraient pour moi
être voilà décoré de de je sais pas la
la légion d'honneur ou en tout cas de
sorte de croix de guerre en tout cas de
la de la de la vérité de l'information
quoi. Et puis on les traite comme des
criminels. Voilà. Non seulement ils sont
pas protégés, mais on les traite comme
la lit de la société quoi. Donc on est
on est dans un cadre où voilà, on voit
que la transparence auprès des puissants
est quelque chose qui est qui vous
conduit en gros en prison ou dans une
ambassade dans lequelle vous restez
toute votre vie.
Et par contre la transparence au niveau
des citoyens, ça c'est c'est voulu,
décider,
disséminer, maximiser, généraliser et
là-dessus, il y a pas de évidemment ceux
qui la font n'iront jamais en prison
quoi. Donc
big brother, big m big data, big tata,
c'est
Ouais. Moi je je j'aime bien délirer
avec ces ces mots-là parce qu'on est on
est parti au départ de bon l'idée de Bri
Brother de de d'Orwell qui est quand
même le livre pour moi de voilà de la
société disciplinaire quoi de poussé à
son extrême.
voilà 84 donc tu tu vois si tu reprends
Michel Fouco qui désigne voilà il
désigne les trois grands régimes de
pouvoir. Tuas le régime féodal qui en
gros arrive à peu près jusqu'au 18e
siècle. Ensuite tu as vraiment le régime
disciplinaire qui est un pouvoir exercé
sur les corps dans un temps donné. et
dans des espaces fermés type voilà
usine, hôpitaux, prison, école et
cetera. Puis après, on rentre
normalement à partir on va dire de après
la deè guerre mondiale mais surtout les
années 60 70, on rentre dans voilà ce
que ce que Fouo appelle le régime de
normalisation et que de l'os va
reprendre en disant c'est le c'est le
régime de contrôle. Donc un système
beaucoup plus insidieux, subtil, non
pyramidal, non dictatorial où l'autorité
se cache euh et qui exerce voilà qui
s'exerce sur les individus de façon très
fine. Et puis nous on est arrivé à un
système encore plus subtil avec
l'arrivée des réseaux d'internet,
smartphone et cetera. C'estàd ce que
j'appelle moi le régime de trace quoi,
société de trace
où du coup ben on n plus du tout dans le
dans le Big Brother. C'est pas le grand
frère, c'est pas cette espèce de figure
de de voilà de de dictateur qui nous qui
nous surplombe et qui nous surveille,
mais c'est plutôt une sorte de au
départ, moi je disais Big Moer,
c'estàdire une sorte de mer couvante
comme ça qui nous cajolle, espèce de
technococon autour de nous qui s'est qui
est devenu de plus en plus épais, de
plus en plus tissé et qui est constitué
ben sur la première course par le
smartphone et puis ensuite tous les
écrans qui sont autour de nous et qui
fait que effectivement entouré d'appli,
entouré de logiciels, entouré de
d'outils en fait à fluidifier nos vies,
à les rendre commode. On se on se
retrouve
et ben dans cette espèce de couveuse
quoi, dans cette espèce de couveuse qui
qui nous qui nous enre, qui flatte nos
égos et sur lequel bah les ados se
construisent, ça couche. Moi je dis
voilà, il s'accouche dans une espèce de
de douceur à travers ce ce technococon.
Donc on est Ouais. pour moi beaucoup
plus sur sur Big Mozor. Puis après ça
dérive un peu je délirais sur Big data
Big Tata mais parce que parce que c'est
ça c'est un peu la voilà la tente la
tente flippante qui est celle qui
récupère les données qu'on donne très
tranquillement à Big Mozer qu'on cède
tranquillement à Big Mozer parce queon
voit pas on voit pas en quoi notre vie
privée est attaquée réellement on voit
pas ce qu'ils font de ces données. Donc
on les lègue dans la douceur et puis
derrière Big Tata les récupère et puis
et puis évidemment fait tous les
systèmes de corrélation pour pour nous
cerner, pour nous profiler, pour nous
proposer les pubs dont on dont on est
censé avoir envie et nous pousser vers
des directions qui qui sont qui sont les
plus plus profitables pour eux quoi.
Donc donc ouais, il y a une sorte de
d'affiliation comme ça. Il a toute la
famille qui s'est mis en place et on est
au bout. Ouais. quand tu vois des
lanceurs d'alerte comme Assange, Snowden
ou d'autres montrer euh la vraie face de
de Big Mozer, Big Brother
et que notre gouvernement euh lui
accorde pas leur accorde pas l'asile ou
autre protection.
Toi, en tant que français, auteur,
intellectuel, euh tu as envie de dire un
message, dire quelque chose ? Ouais mais
moi je y a tu vois il y a deux choses
qui me frappe sur Snowden ou Assange,
c'est que déjà bon évidemment les les
les puissants non
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont révélé ?
Qu'est-ce qu'ils ont révélé ? Bah c'est
c'estàd que ce que bon je te parle pas
d'Astange et de toute la révélation sur
les Wikileaks et cetera enfin qui qui
sont qui sont colossales mais si tu veux
et qu'il faut fouiller qu'il faut
chercher, il faut il faut faire un vrai
boulot journalistique pour extirper la
valeur de ces tu vois si tu prends les
Football League, moi je m'intéresse au
foot. Bon, c'est super intéressant de de
d'aller voir ce qui se passe. Qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé sur le procès de Ronaldo
? Est-ce qu'il a violé, pas violé,
comment se passent les transferts, quels
sont les magouilles derrière. Bon mais
il faut faire un vrai travail
journalistique derrière ce qui ce qui
demande du temps. Bon mais si tu veux si
tu prends Snowden qui a été quand même
la bombe atomique enfin sur sur la
révélation moi même moi qui bossais sur
ces sujets depuis les années en gros 95
puisque je sors la zone du dehor en 95
où déjà j'exposais au maximum cette
espèce de logique panoptique voilà se
disséminant partout dans le corps social
et c'est vraiment le thème du livre même
moi je je prends une claque dans la
gueule quoi. C'està dire, je je je me
dis OK, j'ai fictionné ça mais c'est
beaucoup plus profond, beaucoup plus
plus intense, beaucoup plus généralisé.
Tu vois quand j'ai commencé à regarder
enfin à voir les logiciels, tu sais
qu'ils utilisent
où tu peux chercher en gros n'importe
qui, n'importe quel. Donc soit tu
cherches de façon massifiée sur un site
qui a consulté ce site, soit tu cherches
sur une un mail particulier, un certain
nombre d'infos, enfin tu as tous les
moyens de tri et de recherche possible
et tu prends ce choc là et et finalement
rien. C'està-dire que bien sûr les
gouvernements parce que Orange
évidemment vend les datas d avec la NSA
tout ça on peut tout à fait l'imaginer
tu vois mais que même sur les gens il y
a pas une espèce d'explosion de réaction
tu vois tu tu tout le monde dit wou
c'est fou quand même c'est incroyable et
puis what rien tu vois en réalité quoi.
Et et moi je serai Snowdon j' j'aurais
profondément les boules parce que quand
même il fait ce qui est pour moi dans
dans le mode de révélation le plus
puissant de ce qu'on a pu faire ces
dernières années il est numéro 1 quoi.
Tu vois, pour moi, c'est plus fort que
la guerre en Irak. C'est plus fort que
que le mensonge de la guerre en Irak.
C'est tu peux pas aller plus loin que ce
qu'il a fait. Donc, tu t'attends, moi si
j'avais ça en récit en fiction, tu
t'attends à quelque chose de massif,
quoi, tu vois. Et en fait, il se passe
rien. Et moi, je me suis posé la
question, je me suis dit "Mais mais
pourquoi en réalité ça ne produit pas
d'effet ? Pourquoi les gens restent en
quelque sorte anesthési ou
catatonie émotionnelle ?"
En catatonie émotionnelle ? Ouais.
Ouais, tout à fait, si tu veux, c'est
c'est un très bon terme. Et en fait, moi
la théorie que je développe là-dessus,
enfin la vision que j'en ai, c'est que
finalement si tu regardes bien, et c'est
un peu la la théorie de la zone du
dehors, mon premier livre, mais c'est
encore plus la théorie dans les furtifs
là, le le dernier, c'est que en fait le
contrôle est devenu une sorte d'étos
contemporain, c'est-à-dire un
comportement généralisé dans la plupart
des individus et de la population.
C'estàd que c'est plus du tout quelque
chose qui vient du haut, qui descend sur
nous. C'est quelque chose qui est
quasiment horizontalisé. C'est-à-dire
que aujourd'hui, moi je dis souvent, tu
vas à l'entretien l'embauche, tu vas
googliser ton patron et regarder un peu
ce qu'il a fait, regarder ses vidéos,
regarder ce qu' la boîte. Lui, le
patron, il va embaucher, généralement
parce que c'est ce qu'ils font, il va
embaucher un hackur euh qui va euh aller
sur ton compte Facebook et regarder. En
gros,
c'est pas un cœur de la plupart du
temps.
Oui, mais bon, voilà, c'est c'est enfin
c'est c'est du c'est du bas niveau de de
HAC, quoi, tu vois. Mais
donc, il va voir et il va commencer à
regarder ce que tu as fait peut-être au
niveau syndical, au niveau de la
militance.
dans les couples, tu vas voir le voilà
le mec, il va regarder tout d'un coup,
il va aller choper le smartphone de sa
copine pour voir un peu les textos qu'
qu'elle envoie et la copine, elle va
aller voir les sites, l'historique des
sites pour regarder un peu quel site
porno il regarde ou qu'est-ce qui se
passe. Tu vois, s'il a s'il a une
copine, la fille va surveiller son père,
le père va surveiller sa fille, les
collègues entre eux vont se surveiller
et cetera. Donc, on a tous appris à
utiliser ces ces outils-là pour et en
fait quand tu regardes pour se rassurer
quoi, c'est-à-dire pour conjurer un
ensemble d'incertitude dans lequel
c'estàd l'incertitude que euh ma femme
me soit fidèle par exemple ou
l'incertitude que mon patron soit
vraiment un type bien ou l'incertitude
que l'employé soit pas le premier mec
qui va te montrer un syndical dans ta
boîte, tu vois. Voilà. Donc sur ces
aspects-l te rends compte que cette
pratique de contrôle, elle est tissée.
Moi ce que j'appelle l'intercontrôle,
voilà, horizontal. Et puis après, tu as
des pratiques qui sont presque
intériorisées que j'appelle intra
contrôle ou self contrôle où bah tu as
tendance à t'autant censurer un petit
peu parce que tu sais pas par qui va
être lu ton mail, tu sais pas par qui va
être lu ton tweet, tu sais pas euh qui
va regarder ton smartphone, tu tu sais
pas si ta vidéo elle va être voilà. Donc
tu as toute une pratique. Moi j'avais
été frappé aussi. Par exemple, tu vas au
festival de Cannque que les fêtes sont
complètement pourries au festival de
Cann parce que tout le monde a un
smartphone, tout le monde peut filmer et
tout le monde a peur qu'il un leak
arrive sur le réseau et surtout auprès
des stars. Et donc bah les fêtes elles
sont shutdown un peu parce queil y a
cette pratique d'intrautensure, s
contrôle. Donc si tu prends
intracontrôle, intercontrôle, contrôle
vertical exercé quand même par bah nos
fournisseurs d'accès, par le
gouvernement, par les gafas et cetera,
tu arrives finalement à un maillage
extrêmement dense, extrêmement
extrêmement fin de contrôle et surtout
dans lequel tout le monde est à son
petit niveau relais. Ce qui fait que
quand Snowden révèle ça, moi j'ai le
sentiment que les gens disent "Ouais,
mais au fond, on fait tous un peu ça
quoi." Ils sont pas si voilà, ils sont
pas si frappés, ils sont pas si choqués
que ça parce que c'est devenu aussi une
façon où tu filmes dans la rue, tu vois,
il y a la moindre agression, les gens
filment, il y a le moindre Donc même
l'outil de fait de pouvoir filmer à
n'importe quelle maman, c'est un vrai
outil de contrôle en réalité. C'est un
vrai outil panoptique quoi. Donc voilà,
moi je je pense qu'il y a il y a un
phénomène comme ça. Donc ça révèle
beaucoup de choses sur voilà sur l'étos
contemporain qui est un éthos pour moi
vraiment de contrôle et qui et alors moi
voilà après j'étais plus loin si tu veux
je me suis interrogé aussi pourquoi
pourquoi cette volonté de contrôle
qu'est-ce qui se passe qui fait que
cette société là a a tendance à
fonctionner sur cetos là et puis tu
réfléchis effectivement tu te rends
compte que il y a une façon de vivre
aujourd'hui c'est on est une société
moléculaire c'est on est plus cette
société molaire qui fonctionne par masse
d'ouvriers on est dans une société très
liquide chacun a sa petite particule
chacun se déplace comme ça de façon
assez euh assez individualisée. Et plus
tu es individualisé, plus tu as besoin
de te protéger, plus tu es fragile, plus
tu es vulnérable et plus tu es
vulnérable, plus tu vas utiliser des
outils techniques pour te protéger, pour
filtrer tes communautés par exemple,
pour dire "J'ai pas envie de me
confronter avec des gens qui pensent
Front national. Donc je vais faire des
bulles de filtres dans mes communautés.
Je vais je vais faire mes fils Twitter
qui me correspondent à moi. Je vais
regarder les sites qui m'intéressent
moi, mais surtout je vais pas être
dérangé par des par des images que je
veux pas." voir c'est que tu conjures
tout un ensemble d'altérité de rapport
avec le dehors pour rester dans une
sphère qui va te rassurer et qui va
conjurer tout un ensemble de peur
d'angoisse que tu as et mais qui est
généré par ces sociétés de pour moi en
tout cas d'hypercétition et qui fait que
en étant particule isolé non relié à des
communautés naturelles, on a tendance à
à se servir de la techno pour voilà pour
nous protéger et donc c'est cette cette
façon de contrôler est aussi une façon
de répondre aux peurs, aux angoisses et
à l'incertitude qui nous euh qui nous
entoure. Donc c'est c'est complexe.
C'est pour ça que c'est complexe de
voilà.
Tu suis un peu Black Mirror ?
Ouais, bien sûr. Ouais,
j'adore. J'adore. Ben, Black Mirror,
c'est bon, d'abord, c'est la première
série qui a qui a qui a envisagé la
techno d'un point de vue réellement
technocritique. C'estàd que la SF, je
suis bien placé pour
Je te coupe, je te dis maintenant à
chaque fois qu'on on objecte des
critiques à la techno,
on se fait tout de suite relayer comme
technophobe,
arriéré, genre limite à mich, tu vois.
euh continue, on revient sur cette
question juste après.
Oui, mais non, mais moi là-dessus, j'ai
j'ai vraiment j'ai pas de souci vraiment
à répondre parce que en tant que
science-fiction, déjà la technologie
pour nous, c'est le cœur de ce qu'on de
ce qu'on traite, c'est le cœur de ce
qu'on aborde. Moi je je considère que la
science-fiction est vraiment le genre
littéraire qui pose le paradigme
technologique comme central et qui
essaie de comprendre comment l'homme se
réinvente à travers la technologie.
Voilà. euh et comment la technologie
donc vient impacter à la fois le le
rapport qu'on a au monde, à la fois le
rapport qu'on a aux autres, mais aussi
et peut-être plus important encore le
rapport qu'on a à soi, la façon dont on
se construit soi-même. Quand tu prends
un un ados, tu vois que sa construction
personnelle passe par les réseaux
sociaux, elle passe par les jeux vidéos
énormément. C'estàd qu'ils vont jouer 20
ou 25 heures. Et la façon dont ils vont
construire même leur capacité cognitive,
elle va elle va elle va passer par les
jeux vidéos, la spatialisation. Tu vois,
si tuas Fortnite, ben tu forcément tu as
une capacité de spatialisation énorme
parce qu'il faut que tu les maps en
tête, que tu te déplaces et cetera. Bon,
donc moi je considère que voilà sur le
sur l'aspect technologique et Black
Mirror, c'est le première série en tout
cas qui est sortie avec cette qualité
qui est une approche technocritique qui
qui regarde le miroir justement le
au-delà du miroir de la technologie et
cet écran noir qui qui est face à nous
et surtout qu' avait une capacité
narrative que je trouve extraordinaire à
te mettre mal à l'aise quoi.
C'est-à-dire que tu sors de la série, tu
sors des épisodes et tu es dans une
sentiment que moi j'avais jamais éprouvé
avant.
C'est pas que tu es choqué, c'est pas
que tu es révolté, c'est que tu es mal à
l'aise, quoi. C'est-à-dire que ils font
passer la ligne de récit à l'intérieur
de toi. Et tu te rends compte que
l'utilisation des technologies qui te
montre et leur perversion, il y a une
partie de toi qui est déjà dans ces
perversions là, qui qui fait déjà partie
de ces perversions là. Et c'est pour ça
que c'est si c'est si déroutant. Moi un
épisode qui m'avait par exemple
extraordinairement touché parce que je
travaillais sur ce sujet sur un jeu
vidéo, c'était la mémoire. J'avais créé
un jeu vidéo comme ça qui s'appelait
Rumble Bemy enfin on l'avait créé à 80
mais moi j'étais directeur narratif et
le principe c'était toute la mémoire
humaine est digitalisé est numérisé donc
dans ce monde là tu jouais tu jouais un
hackeur qui était capable de remixer le
cerveau des gens qui remixait la mémoire
des gens mais surtout dans ce mondeel tu
avais une banque qui s'appelait Memorize
qui qui récupérait toutes les segments
mémoriels des gens que les gens
déposaient chaque jour de des segments
de mémoire soit positif soit négatif
pour s'en débarrasser en banque et ces
banques étaient par ailleurs payé la et
cetera. Et donc j'avais beaucoup
travaillé sur cet enjeu de la mémoire,
comment l'utiliser, comment la vendre,
comment la trafiquer, comment la remixer
et cetera. Et puis arrive ce cet épisode
de de Black Mirror qui avait lieu
d'ailleurs après qui s'appelait The
Grain où c'est pareil, ils ont il a une
espèce de petite
c'est pas une puce mais c'est une graine
dans le cerveau qui permet d'enregistrer
chacun des moments que tu vis comme si
là on était on était également
enregistré, on l' d'ailleurs mais
et ce qui est génial c'est que eux ils
ont traité cet enjeu de moi je l'avais
traité de façon très politique très il y
avait amnésie internationale qui se
battait contre l'amnémose ou la
mémorisation
extrême de de ce monde. Et là, il le
traite sur un sujet extrêmement simple
mais qui nous touche tous, c'est la
jalousie. Voilà, il traite l'enjeu de la
mémoire totale à travers la jalousie. Si
tu peux mémoriser chacun des moments de
ta vie et revenir sur des scènes où
effectivement il y avait des séductions
entre ton partenaire et quelqu'un
d'autre et que tu peux te repasser ces
scènes, tu vas creuser l'espèce de
paranoï de la jalousie bien plus
intensément que tu l'aurais jamais fait.
Et ça, j'ai trouvé ça fabuleux parce que
ils viennent toucher un affect qui est
personnel et il le traite sur un enjeu
de SF qui est la mémorisation quoi. Et
ça c'est rare de trouver cette qualité
là en narration quoi. C'est la plupart
des gens l'auraient traité de façon
assez lointaine en disant "Oh là là,
regardez, on mémorise tout et puis on
aurait pris un une espèce de de
président dont on avait mémorisé un
moment intime et puis on l'aurait
sorti." tu vois, ça aurait été donné des
choses pas très intéressantes. Là, il
prend une situation concrète euh
personnelle de couple, il la traite sur
l'axe de la jalousie et du coup, tu
ressors mais tu as envie de vomir quoi.
Tu as quelque chose de Donc là-dessus,
ils sont très forts. Après les épisodes,
moi je trouve que les la saison 3 déjà
se se dégrade un peu au sens où ils sont
victimes de
du retour d'état de grâce. C'est-à-dire
qu'il y a des choses qu'ils ont fait, je
pense, avec beaucoup d'instincts,
beaucoup d'intuition et ensuite, ils ont
essayé de systématiser un peu leur leur
leur pratique, c'estàdire de de chercher
le malaise siamment, volontairement,
rationnellement. Et je trouve que ça
pêche quoi. Par exemple, l'épisode de la
de la notation généralisée
qui moi en plus c'est dans la zone
dehors, c'est c'est quelque chose que je
pratique dans la zone dehors, c'est le
classe, c'est classement généralisé de
la population où voilà ton subordonné te
te note, ton patron te note
comme en Chine. Voilà. social crédit,
ton boulanger te note, ton tes fils te
notent, enfin tout le monde te note et
toi tu notes tout le monde. Donc c'était
le même principe et là c'est traité de
façon très didactique. Tu as compris dès
les 5 premières minutes ce qui se passe
et du coup on est plus dans une logique
de message et on n pas le malaise. On
sort on sort de la dimension de malaise.
Ce que je trouve très difficile, voilà,
c'est ça, c'est créer l'identification
au personnage qui fait que une fois que
tu es identifié au personnage, tu vas
ressentir toute son malaise, sa
perversion façon forte. L'épisode génial
par exemple de la de la fille qui perd
son mec.
et qui d'abord discute avec son mec
mort, avec toutes les traces vidéos et
et audio qu'il a laissé. Unia
reconstitue son mec et elle peut
discuter au téléphone avec lui.
Ça par contre, c'est génial parce que
immédiatement tu t'identifies à la
fille, immédiatement tu rentres en elle.
Donc une fois que l'identification est
assurée, tu vas tu vas éprouver tout ce
qu'elle éprouve et tu vas te prendre la
la perversion et le et le mal-être tout
le long de de l'épisode. Il est
magnifique cet épisode. Moi, je trouve
qu'
Laurent Alexandre, ça te parle ? Oui,
bien sûr. Je l'ai rencontré. J'ai eu le
le le malheur de le rencontrer. Ouais.
Ou le bonheur de rencontrer, je sais
pas.
Bah Laurent Alexandre, c'est c'est une
caricature quoi. C'est-à-dire que c'est
Laurent Alexandre, c'est c'est le type
qui a donc fondé Doctimo qui a revendu
quand même 140 millions d'euros, il faut
quand même le savoir, qui après ça a
monté une boîte de de séquençage de gène
et qui est un gars qui pour son plaisir,
je pense son bonheur, sa perversion, son
égocentriste, j'en sais rien, mais a
décidé de d'investir les médias, de
saturer les médias d'une sorte de disque
moi j'appelle le Messi du transhumani.
C'estàd que il amène en France les idées
du transhumanisme tout en seargant de de
n'être comme que dans une forme d'alerte
ou de ou d'avant, je sais pas comment
dire ça, d'avant prou un peu de du
phénomène. Alors qui en fait, il essaie
d'acclimater les idées du transhumanisme
dans la presse française
euh mais toujours il avance comme ça en
disant "Non mais je si vous voulez pas
ce que je voudrais qu' qu'il advienne
mais vous savez quand même c'est ce qui
va arriver quoi. C'est cette idée de
toute façon que vous vouliez ou non ça
va arriver. Et ça c'est la meilleure
méthode pour pour essayer d'emprisonner
mentalement les gens en disant voilà je
préente le futur et je vous dis comment
il va être. Donc croyez ce que vous
voulez, pensez ce que vous voulez, c'est
ce qui va devenir quoi. Et ce qu'il dit,
c'est du bullshit total quand même he
c'est c'est un gars, il faut faut quand
même regarder ce qu'il raconte et c'est
et c'est quand même terrifiant. Il a
fait une conférence tê, je sais pas si
vous l'aviez suivi, où euh il finit sa
conférence tê en en hurlant devant toute
la salle. Il y a des gens dans cette
salle qui vivront 1000 ans, tu vois ?
Donc discours messianique et cetera
parce que évidemment il faut tuer la
mort, il faut tuer le vieillissement,
faut lutter contre la sénaissance et et
bien sûr on va y arriver. Et bon, c'est
la logique de la promesse. Moi, j'ai
beaucoup travaillé sur ce thème du
transhumanisme parce que c'est
intéressant à cause des affects, tu
vois. Moi, j'aime bien voir les affects
qu'il y a derrière tel ou tel système
théorique. C'est aussi mon boulot. Et et
derrière le transhumanisme, il a il y a
vraiment des affectes moi que j'appelle
par religieux qui sont extrêmement
extrêmement puissant. C'est-à-dire que
c'est la même logique que la religion
chrétienne en gros quoi. C'està-dire
qu'on a la logique de Messie. Alors en
France c'est c'est Laurent Alexandre,
c'est RZV évidemment aux États-Unis.
Donc ces messies évidemment comme c'est
des messies, il faut qu'ils aient une
prophétie quoi. Donc la prophétie de rur
vi c'était au départ la singularité
devait arriver en 2029 c'est ce moment
où l'intelligence artificielle
émerge et et évidemment arrive à diriger
l'ensemble des machines et devient plus
puissante que que n'importe quelle
intelligence humaine. Bon et puis après
il s'est rendu compte c'était un peu
près 2029 donc il a fait euh en fait
2045 donc il a décalé. Mais voilà, on
est sur des logiques de prophéties qui
se volent peut-être même
autoréalisatrices alors que de
peur aussi
de peur bien sûr qui joue sur l'affecte
de peur he parce que
la peur c'est bien ça mais la peur c'est
c'est c'est le meilleur des affects
politiques. La peur c'est c'est tu
arrives un peu près à obtenir n'importe
quel vote si tu gères bien la peur. Donc
Front National est construit là-dessus
hein. Donc c'est extrêmement difficile
de faire voter les gens par désir hein.
l' REM aussi. Non, si vous votez pas
pour moi, vous allez avoir la
Ah ben vous allez avoir le Front
National mais c'est c'est tout ce qui
reste hein. Le système a deux tours et
fonctionne comme ça maintenant. C'est
que il suffit d'avoir 20 % pour passer
au deuxème tour et ensuite tu tu génères
la peur généralisée du du Front National
alors qu'ils font une politique de fond
national. Moi je vois je vois absolument
pas la différence entre celle de Macron
et le fond national. Pour moi, ils
préparent l'arrivée des Front National
en réalité. Et et puis là au deuxième
tour, tu as ce que j'appelle moi les
castors moraux qui font barrage quand
c'est l'extrême droite. Donc c'est
castorama, j'appelle ça, tu vois. C'est
vraiment il voilà, ils font barrage et
il croi à faire un acte politique tous
les 5 ans en allant voter pour pour la
marionnette que que le système dominant
mis en place au 2è tour. Donc là sur
Macron, c'est un holdup démocratique
total et et ils ont réussi. Donc ça oui,
mais parce que l'affect de peur est est
le plus facile à mobiliser de tous.
Si je te dis si je te dis faites ce que
vous voulez mais votez Macron, ça te
fait penser à quoi
ça ? Ça veut dire que voilà, on est
les titres de libération.
Ouais, ouais, ouais. Je me souviens
d'util des libération mais il y en a eu
dans toute la presse même part Macron
donc à un moment donné tu tu t'inquiètes
quand même
non ? Bon là-dessus on pourra en parler
des heures. Voilà c'est pour moi c'est
un système totalement exemple. La 5
République doit doit doit être achevé à
coup de à coup de marteau et comme tous
les systèmes au bout d'un certain moment
qui sont en place. des gens ont compris
comment l'utiliser pour pour obtenir le
vote qui qu'il souhaite avoir et et
maintenant il faut vite changer et
détruire cette 5e République, passer à
une 6e, 7e, je sais pas, faire une
constituante ou passer même à d'autres
d'autres régimes complètement
différents. Mais on peut pas rester
comme ça parce que on va avoir le coût à
chaque fois et puis une fois ça va pas
marcher puis on va vraiment avoir le
Front National et contrairement à ce
qu'on croit, le Front National va
évidemment pas défendre le peuple. le
Front National va s'aler avec les
puissances d'argent, va va s'aler avec
l'oligarchie et il commence à y avoir
des prises de contact. Si tu écoutes R
Branco qui est quand même bien informé
sur ces domainesl
qui a accès justement au lx et qui dit
voilà aujourd'hui Marine Le Pen commence
à abandonner toutes les choses qui
faisaient un peu peu barrage avec le
lien avec l'oligarchie notamment
antisémitisme et différentes autres
choses et puis à partir du moment
l'igarchie qu'on comprendra que le Front
National ils ont rien à craindre d'eux
bah ils feront en sorte que ils passent
voilà de toute façon ils sont tout prêt
donc mais de toute façon même la la
politique actuelle elle est tellement
peu différente de ce que le font
national ferait. Je vois pas ce que le
Front National aurait fait de plus sur
la politique migratoire qui a été
odieuse depuis l'arrivée de Macron. Je
vois pas ce qu' aurait fait plus
hein.
Tu as vu l'aquarius
? L'aquarius. Moi je suis soutien, je
suis au comité de soutien l'aquarius.
Donc je j'ai vu ça de près. Donc c'est
juste une honte absolue hein entre
parenthèses. Ça, il faut quand même le
direin. C'est-à-dire que ça, je suis
content de pouvoir en parler un tout
petit peu là sur Syerview, mais
tu as donc des des milliers des milliers
donc de de migrants qui meurent sur les
carneaux pneumatiques qui sont qui sont
fabriqués à la chaîne en plus he dans
des usines libiennes. Donc c'est des
canaux qui sont qui sont faits pour
tenir 10h en réalité.
Donc ils mettent donc c'est des espèces
de boudin comme ça blanc pneumatique
complètement pourri. Il clouent des
planches dessous quoi. Tu sais même pas
comment ça crève pas le le truc. Ils
mettent des migrants ils mettent une
certaine de migrants dessus et puis ils
partent quoi. Donc ils savent que voilà
ils mettent de l'essence dedans. Ils
savent qu'en gros 10 12h après ça ça ne
donc c'est quasiment une condamnation à
mort sauf si sur place tu as
effectivement des des bateaux qui vont
euh qui vont les sauver. Donc ce qui est
quand même délirant, c'est que c'est que
l'Aquarius quand même en assez peu de
temps avait sommé 30000 personnes, tu
vois. Donc tu sauves 30000 vies. Je veux
dire, qu'est-ce que tu peux faire de
mieux que sauver 30000 vies quoi ? Et
puis tu as même pas de poser la question
de dire "Oui, mais c'est des migrants et
cetera." Non, c'est des gens qui sont en
train de se noyer. Tu d'abord tu les
sauves, c'est le code de la merin, tu
sauves d'abord les gens qui sont en
train de se noyer et ensuite tu
réfléchis, tu les accueilles, tu fais ce
que tu peux et cetera, mais d'abord tu
sauves les gens quoi. Voilà. Et ensuite
quand tu vois les témoignages des
migrants, enfin moi j'ai fait les les
soirées Sméranée où tu avais les
témoignages à la fois vidéo et audio des
migrants. Mais franchement moi j'ai
jamais j'ai jamais vu ça. Enfin j'ai
jamais entendu ça. J'ai jamais pensé que
c'était possible quoi. Pour donner juste
un exemple qui qui c'est que très
souvent donc au long du voyage, ils sont
dépouillés, ils ont plus aucun rond et
cetera. très souvent donc ils sont
menacés à des mamans, ils appellent la
famille, ils les menacent avec un
flingue et leur dit "Si vous donnez pas
l'argent, on tue on tue votre fils ou on
tue". Bon, OK, tu as ça, mais tu as des
trucs bien pires encore. Si tu voyages
avec ta femme, ils vont la violer devant
toi, ils vont t'obliger à regarder euh
et tant que tu donnes pas de l'argent ou
tant que tu fais pas ce qu'ils veulent,
tu vois. Et donc tu te retrouves avec
des gens qui sont des purs héros, quoi.
C'estd qui sont survécus, qui sont
encore dans le canal de sauvetage et qui
ensuite sont récupérés par l'aquarius.
Ces gens-là, moi je fais je fais 10
romans sur eux avec juste un récit,
quoi, tu vois ? parce que c'est
tellement incroyable ce qu'ils ont
surmonté que et ces gens-là, on les
rejette quand ils arrivent en France
quoi. Tu vois, c'est
quand Castan quand Castaner dit ils sont
complices dépasseurs.
Non mais c'est complètement hallucinant
quoi. Enfin tu vois c'est
moi je je
Ça c'est ce que j'appelle l'obscénité.
Voilà l'obscénité c'est ça. C'est
l'obscénité. Voilà c'est un point où tu
tu dis quelque chose qui qui est
révoltant. Tu vois, moi quand j'ai
j'entends ça, j'ai envie de mettre
Cassur sur un canau et puis tu vois de
le le mettre au milieu de la mer puis
attendre qu'il coule quoi. Tu vois juste
quoi. Voilà, c'est ça qu'il faudrait
faire parce que je veux dire, c'est
évident que ces gens-là et quand tu vois
les témoignages et quand tu sais d'où
ils viennent, c'est évident que ces
gens-là généralement ils n'ont
absolument aucun autre choix que de
migrer pour s'en sortir. Soit parce
qu'ils viennent de Syrie, soit parce
qu'ils viennent d'Éré, soit qu'il
viennent voilà. Alors tu vas me dire il
y a quelques migrants économiques. Oui,
peut-être. Tu vois, il y en a
quelques-uns, bien sûr, mais tu as la
plupart des gens c'est juste une
question de survie. Donc qu'est-ce que
tu veux faire ? En plus, ils arrivent en
Libye où ils sont exploités, ils sont
mis en prison. C'est que des prisons
privées. Donc c'est c'est juste
incroyable. Quand tu vois, ils sont ils
sont battus. Si travaillent pas, ils
sont battus. S'il meurent pas, c'est
déjà un miracle. Et ensuite quand ils
arrivent enfin sur le canau pneumatique,
tu vois, tu veux pas les sauver. Enfin,
c'est c'est c'est juste ignoble. Enfin,
voilà. Moi je sais pas, je sais pas quel
nom ça peut on peut donner à ça quoi.
Mais moi je trouve ça voilà juste obsène
quoi. Et quand tu vois ce que ça
représente en plus flux migratoire on a
67 millions de d'habitants. Moi un coup
j'avais calculé ça voulait dire ce qu'on
accueillait ça voulait dire accueillir
une personne sur 7000. C'estàd que tu as
6999 français et toi ils se réunissent
c'est 699 français puis il y a une
personne qui arrive sur la plage et tu
leur demandes vous l'accueillez ou pas ?
Parce que quand même quand même pour la
France tu vois c'est ça le chiffre hein
30000 sur 67 million ça donne ça tu
vois. Donc même si tu te dis bah alors
on va on va allez quand même on en
accueille 5 sur 7000
qu'est-ce que ça va changer ? Enfin, tu
vois, ça va rien changer et au
contraire, c'est une richesse, c'est un
apport, c'est une culture, c'est ça peut
que bonifier la société française en
plus quoi, tu vois. Donc donc ça c'est
Ouais. Ouais. C'est particulièrement
horrible quoi. Et ça c'est extrêmement
impressionnant aussi de voir à quel
point c'est passé sous le sous silence,
sous le boissau. Rien que donner un
pavillon à l'air, tu peux ne pas être
d'accord avec l'Aquarius quoi, mais à un
moment donné, tu es la France, tu es le
pays de droit de l'homme, donc tu leur
donnes au moins un pavillon qui puisse
continuer à sauver les gens. Enfin, tu
vois, c'est quand même le la base de
tout. C'est quand même une honte absolue
que que que Macron ne délivre pas un
pavillon pour l'Aquarius. C'est quelque
chose qui qui a qui qui a pas de nom.
C'est c'est la honte totale. C'est c'est
pire que la honte, quoi. C'est c'est un
crime contre l'humanité. Là, il faut le
dire, parce que c'est vraiment un crime
sur des dizaines et des dizaines de
milliers de personnes qui crèvent dont
on a même pas les sépultures, dont on
sait même pas le nombre. Voilà, on sait
qu'on a sauvé 30000, ça veut dire qu'
combien sont morts ? C'est euh
certainement plus de 100000. Donc tu
appelles ça comment à un moment donné ?
C'est pas pour lancer des grands mots,
tu vois. Mais tu appelles ça comment ?
Un génocide.
Ouais, c'est un génocide par défaut.
Ouais, c'est un génocide en creux.
Voilà, un génocide consenti, conscient
et ancreux. C'est qu'ils savent
parfaitement tout ce que je raconte là.
Là, j'invente rien. Je révèle pas
quelque chose que personne sait. Tout le
monde est au courant de ça. Macron est
au courant de ça. Tout tout voilà, tous
les ministres, tout le gouvernement est
au courant de ça. Ils savent
parfaitement ce qu'ils font. Ils le font
en pleine conscience quoi. C'est quand
même Et là, il faut saluer Angela Merkel
sur ce qu'elle a fait sur la politique
migratoire quand elle est arrivée et et
malgré toutes les oppositions, elle a
dit "Allez, on va accueillir un million
de bah bravo. Moi, je suis je suis pas
pour la politique de Merkel, mais
là-dessus, elle a elle a juste une
conscience, une éthique certainement
protestante et cetera, mais elle l'a
fait." Voilà. Nous, on est juste dans la
honte absolue he Hollande Hollande comme
Macron.
Tu vois la France commande en 3 ans 5
ans ? C'est quoi ton
Moi, j'ai beaucoup d'espoir, voilà. Bon,
j'ai beaucoup d'espoir sur ce qui se
passe sur les gilets jaunes et sur ce
que ça trahit surtout et sur ce que ça
révèle. Moi, j'ai l'impression qu'on est
au bout quand même d'un système. Voilà,
le euh
c'est ça le livre de R Branco sur
crépuscu. J'ai massé le terme, voilà,
j'ai massé ce terme. C'estàd que je je
pense comme lui que on arrive à une zone
crépusculaire. C'estàd qu'on arrive la
5e est exang la 5e République est exang
pour la première fois des gens qui
étaient vraiment la première comme on
dit le premier niveau des inclus. Les
gilets jaunes c'est ça c'est le premier
niveau des inclus. C'est c'est pas les
gens qui sont chômeurs, c'est pas les
gens qui sont exclus, c'est pas les gens
qui sont sans papier et cetera. C'est
des gens qui travaillent tous quasiment
qui sont petits commerçants ou salariés
SMIC. Donc qui ont un boulot, qui ont un
clu, qui ont joué le jeu. Voilà, c'est
les gens qui ont joué le jeu. On leur a
dit si vous bossez bien, si vous êtes
sérieux, si vous votez bien, vous allez
avoir une vie correcte avec votre petit
pavillon, avec votre portique pour les
enfants, avec votre chien et la niche
pour le chien. Voilà, vous pourrez
partir en vacances 5 semaines par an.
Voilà ce qu'on leur a vendu quoi. En
tout cas, ce à quoi ils ont cru et c'est
ce que ce système devrait enfin système
riche comme le nôtre devrait accorder à
la majorité des gens. Ils ont joué le
jeu et ils se rendent compte au bout
d'un moment que on les a baisé.
Voilà, tout simplement, faut dire les
choses vulgairement, mais c'est-à-dire
que en moi je dirais en 35 ans, c'est
depuis le tournant de la rigueur en 83
en France, euh le capitalisme a accruir
d'une façon exorbitante. Voilà, quand tu
regardes, il il y a vraiment un
graphique qu'il faut vraiment regarder.
C'est le graphique qui te monte sur
c'est sur le même graphique hein qui te
montre notamment la baisse de l'impôt
sur le revenu pour les tranches
supérieures. Par exemple, moi à l'époque
où j'étais encore à l'essle de commerce
et cetera, c'était 60 % le taux
d'imposition sur les revenus.
Maintenant, avec la flat taxe, on va
descendre à 30 % donc divisé par 2. Tu
prends la courbe aussi de l'imposition
sur les héritages. Elle a chuté de de
d'un coefficient 2. D'accord.
C'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui la fille de
Bencour peut récupérer la totalité en
gros de la fortune de sa mère et qui est
complètement exorbitante hein. C'est je
crois qu'elle est à 35 ou 40 milliards
de de de d'euros.
Et ben rien n'est pris par l'État. Alors
que moi je suis désolé, tu devrais pas
irriter de la fortune de tes parents. Tu
devrais toucher un tout petit peu
quelque chose mais sur les 40 milliards,
bah on devrait récupérer 39 ou tu vois
ou 39 et demi et les redonner à l'état.
Et puis la fle en courbe, elle fait
comme tout le monde. Elle se construit
sa vie, elle devient riche. Si elle
arrive à devenir riche, elle se bat
quoi, tu vois. Et là, on est un système
qui est complètement système monarchique
quoi, de transmission quoi. De la même
façon, si tu regardes l'impôt sur les
sociétés, moi à l'époque où je suis allé
sex. D'accord ? Donc 50 % des bénéfices
sont imposés dans les boîtes et sont
donnés à l'État. Aujourd'hui, on est
autour de 25 30 %. D'accord ? Tu
regardes la répartition capital travail,
c'estd que sur 100 généré par une
entreprise
100 de valeur, je crois qu'on est passé
de 70 30 c'estd en gros 70 pour les
salariés et 30 pour le pour le capital.
Maintenant on est à 60 40 tu vois. Donc
tout est comme ça. C'estàd que nous on a
été la génération, moi je suis né en 69,
j'ai été la génération enfoncée. Je suis
la génération qui a tout perdu. En tout
cas, c'est la génération de la
régression. Tu vois, on a parlé des 30
des 30 glorieuses. Moi je dis voilà, on
est dans les 30 honteuses. Voilà, nous
on a un des chiffres aussi parce que ça
les gens ils se rendent pas compte un
truc moi qui m'a toujours frappé, c'est
que à l'époque de mon de je prends mes
mes parents et moi, je suis un peu près
du même niveau de vie que mes parents.
Ma mère était prof d'anglais, ma copine
est prof de français et cetera. Moi je
suis indépendant, mon père était
carrossier. Donc on est à peu près au
même niveau de vie. Il fallait 10 ans à
leur époque pour acheter une maison, tu
vois, une maison normale. Il en faut 20.
Voilà, exactement, il en faut 20. Et ça
c'est l'INC hein, c'est pas des trucs
qu'on qu'on jette en l'air hein, c'est
des chiffres de l'INC.
Donc qu'est-ce qui s'est passé quoi ? On
est devenu moins riche, c'est devenu
moins riche, on produit moins, on
travaille moins. Non, c'est juste que
l'extion de valeur a été beaucoup plus
massive sur les 30 dernières années et
que progressivement, ils ont réussi à
accumuler des sommes colossales. Bon, on
le dit, on le sait he les les 10
premiers milliardaires en France par
exemple, c'est 262 milliards
d'euros, tu vois. Alors, je me suis
amusé l'autre fois, je me suis dit mais
ça fait combien en SMIC ? Tu vois,
j'essayie de de trouver un chiffre de
parce que j'arrivais pas à le transcrire
en terme de valeur, tu vois. J'essayie
de trouver un moyen pour me dire
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire en fait cette
somme qui est colossale. Et j'ai et j'ai
calculé, donc j'ai regardé, tu vois, un
SMIC annuel, c'est en gros chargé,
c'estàd que si tu payes toutes les
charges, si tu payes le poste de
travail, si tu payes la formation, les
coûts d'embauche, le le bureau dans
lequel le smicer machin, c'est 25000 €
par an en gros quoi, tu vois. Donc quand
tu calcules, tu arrives à 100 millions
d'années de SMIC, tu vois. Donc ces gars
possèdent 10 millions d'allic. Donc il
pourrai payer pendant un an 100 millions
de personnes, tu vois, ou 1 million de
personnes pendant 10 ans, tu vois. C'est
donc c'est complètement fou quoi. Tu
imagines à 10 personnes, ils peuvent
payer 100 millions de personnes au SMIC
pendant 1 an, tu vois, avec toutes les
charges attenantes, tu vois. Et là, tu
fais
euh qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Où c'est
qu'on s'est gouré, où c'est qu'on s'est
fait avoir, quoi ? Tu vois, c'est
comment t'explique cette cette
soumission qu'on sentit, cette
catatonie de des des foules par rapport
à la réalité des de l'arnaque telle que
tu la présentes, tel que on peut la
présenter aussi sur Syerview.
Euh comment tu'expliques le fait que les
gens bougent pas et on est on est
français ? C'estàd que pourquoi on on
retourne pas les tables ? Il y a il y a
il y a plusieurs bien sûr, il y a
plusieurs raisons. Bon, pour moi, une
des raisons la principale, c'est qu'on
on nous maintient juste au-dessus de la
ligne de confort. C'estàdire que la
plupart des gens sont juste au-dessus du
seuil de pauvreté, c'est-à-dire que sont
dans un niveau de confort qui fait que
bon, c'est pas si mal. Donc, on tolère à
peu près tout. On on se rebelle pas
parce qu'on n'est pas mis dans la
situation. Et là, les gilets jaunes,
c'est le moment où justement cette
génération là passe sous le seuil de
confort quoi. Et du coup, se dit "Non,
mais c'est plus possible là, j'en ai
j'en ai marre, quoi." Voilà. et puis il
voit tout ça et ce la deuxième chose
c'est que bah en France particulièrement
c'est que le voilà c'est que la presse a
été entièrement fagocitée aujourd'hui
par les milliardaires. Aujourd'hui tuas
tu as un graphique magnifique de
d'ailleurs qui est fait par le monde
diplomatique et voilà quand tu regardes
la presse libre d'ailleurs c'est il
reste plus grand chose he mais tu
regardes tuas tu as une carte fait par
le monde diplomatique qui te regarde
tout le système de dépendance de tous
les quotidiens de toute la presse en
fonction des milliardaires français
quoi. Et en gros une dizaine de
milliardaires français tient la quasi
totalité de la presse. Si tu regardes ce
qui reste, il reste bon voilà des SV, il
reste bon le Can a enchaîné évidemment
hein, Mia Part, il reste bah Fakir le
ravi des petits trucs comme ça, il reste
le monde diplô
quand même he c'est bah si reste sur
image des choses comme ça hors série
enfin quelques petites
et tout le reste même des journaux
soi-disant de gauche voilà même des
journaux historiques comme Libération
bah sont détenus par voilà Patrick Dra
qui est un milliardaire qui le monde a
été le monde c'est une honte absolu ce
que c'est devenu. Euh moi le monde qui
était mon journal de référence que je
quand je arrivais sur internet, mon
premier vecteur d'information il y a
encore 5 ans c'était c'était de d'aller
sur le site du monde. Aujourd'hui c'est
devenu juste illisible. C'est c'est la
pravda du macronisme quoi. J'ai jamais
vu ça. Qu'en France ça soit comme ça.
C'est il y a une vellererie. Je veux
dire n'importe quelle décision du
gouvernement elle est présentée comme
comment on dirait un communiqué de
presse du gouvernement quoi. C'est c'est
les communiqués de presse. C'est même
plus les articles critiques ou de mise
en perspective. Le monde s'est effondré.
C'est c'est ce journal c'est effondré.
C'est c'est il faut que les gens se
rendent compte, c'est c'est juste
pathétique quoi. Voilà. Donc là, il
reste plus. Donc ça ben ça produit et ça
le le livre de R Branco Crépuscule le
montre aussi super bien, c'est que ça
produit
euh effectivement une manipulation et
moi j'aime pas dire ça, j'aime pas, tu
vois, je suis pas sur complot médiatique
et cetera, mais à un moment donné, tu es
quand même obligé de te rendre compte
que même quand tu es informé, même moi,
tu lis la presse tous les jours. Moi, je
fais ça depuis des années, je lis la
presse tous les jours. Même moi les
phénomènes dont je me rendais pas compte
et j'ai il m'a fallu longtemps pour
comprendre que le monde était devenu la
Pravda parce que je continu à croire une
forme de neutralité
et non cette neutralité a été perdue
parce que Xavien l'a racheté parce que
voilà et parce que tous les tous les
tous les grands quotidiens toutes les
les grands les grands magazines de news
sont détenus par des milliardaires qui
sans même intervenir directement juste
par des politiques assez astucieuses et
ben ne sélectionne que des journalistes
qui vont aller dans le sens de la ligne
lect ultralibérale he qui est celle de
des milliardaires qui possèdent ces
journaux. Et puis après il y a il y a ce
phénomène que quand tu possèdes un
journal, tu peux pousser tel ou tel
politicien. Donc les politiciens le
savent. Donc les politiciens mettent en
place des politiques qui te favorisent
toi en tant que milliardaire parce que
ils savent que que ta carrière va
dépendre de la façon dont toi tu vas les
valoriser au niveau médiatique. Donc
c'est un échange comme ça de service que
don Macron a a bénéficié à bloc. Donc ça
ça fait peur. Et voilà. Et là c'est
pareil c'est qu'on a pas été assez
vigilant. Là, on s'est laissé endormir,
on a on a cru à la liberté de la presse
parce qu'on nous dit qu'on est en
démocratie. Euh
voilà. Donc euh
c'est ces deux niveaux-là. Après bon, il
y a plein de raisons. Mais moi une autre
raison qui qu'on dit pas beaucoup
après c'est mon délire là c'est mon
délire d'auteur de SF mais je crois
beaucoup à ça c'est que j'ai j'ai le
sentiment que et là c'est le rapport
technocapitalisme
et politique c'est que j'ai le sentiment
que depuis qu'on a le smartphone dans la
main depuis qu'on a l'outil internet
pouvoir que nous donnent ces
technologies qui est un pouvoir immédiat
mineur en réalité tu vois qui est un
pouvoir de choix de paramétrage de de
choisir tel appli de le pouvoir de faire
faire. Moi ce que j'appelle le pouvoir
de faire faire à la machine, ce que tu
veux pas faire directement. Donc toute
cette commodité, cette facilité que ta
technologie, ça fait que ça remplit la
case pouvoir pour les gens. C'est-à-dire
qu'ils ont l'impression de diriger leur
vie parce qu'ils redirigent leurs
applis, leurs smartphones et parce
queils peuvent intervenir directement
sur leur réalité proche grâce à l'outil
technologique. Et du coup, tout cet
enjeu de lutte politique de dire il faut
que je reprenne le pouvoir en tant que
citoyen, il faut que je me batte pour
que les lois changent, il faut que
j'empêche Macron de devenir président et
cetera, ça paraît extrêmement lointain,
ça paraît extrêmement fumeux, ça paraît
être beaucoup de travail euh et sans
pouvoir direct parce que c'est beaucoup
d'impuissance la militance. Si tu
milites, tu le sais vraiment, c'est que
voilà plein de fois tu milites. Moi j'ai
mité contre la voie de travail au bout
de je sais pas combien de manif, il se
passe rien. Toutes les lois passent,
c'est horrible et toi tu es comme un
con. Donc euh si tu as cette espèce de
technoco autour de toi que tu peux
manipuler quoi, moi j'avais ça les
paramètres tu vois c'est mes maîtres M
TR quoi. Tu vois, c'est-à-dire que tu
paramètres tes applis, tu personnalises,
tu customises tout ton technococcon
autour de toi. D'abord ça te filtre le
monde comme comme je l'ai dit, ça te
fluidifie la vie, mais aussi ça te donne
le sentiment de contrôler, d'avoir un
pouvoir, une maîtrise. Voilà. Et cette
maîtrise qu'on te donne de façon proche
et ben le fait que tu as moins envie de
lutter, moins envie de te battre, moins
envie de militer, moins envie d'aller
d'aller sauver les les migrants sur
l'aquarius, ça te paraît très lointain.
Et dans ce cadre là, le surgissement des
gilets jaunes pour moi a été une divine
surprise parce que je m'attendais plus à
ce que les gens arrivent à s'extirper
des technococons, à percer le au couteau
le l'espèce de de tissage de fibre
optique et retrouve le plaisir de
parler, d'aller sur les ronds-points, de
découvrir les amitiés de et ça ça a été
vraiment extraordinaire. Mais ça montre
aussi le déficit de lien qu'on a qu'on a
acquis. Je pense que ce qui fait que les
g jaunes ça durent, c'est qu'il y a des
amitiés créées quoi. Les gens ont du
plaisir à se retrouver tout le samedi.
C'est pour ça qui et ça c'est génial,
c'est l'amitié qui fait que ça ça tient,
ça monte, ça ça se maintient et que
progressivement ça va produire. Donc moi
la France en 3 ans bah j'espère en tout
cas dans mon livre il y a des j'arrive à
des agues, à des zones autogouvernées.
On reprend des îles, on reprend des îs
sur les fleuves, on reprend zone
à défendre. Ouais, c'est des zones à
défendre version
version étendue pour moi parce que zone
à défendre ce qui m'a toujours gêné
c'était l'idée que on s'est mobilisé
contre un aéroport
donc ça permet de mobiliser par le
négatif hein. C'est une ennemi commun,
c'est la meilleure façon de souder les
gens mais voilà moi le Zade des fois je
dis il faudrait ça soit une zone à
désirer quoi. C'estàd qu'il faut ça soit
une zone qu'on désire mettre en place,
sur lequel on définit de nouvelles
règles de vie euh plus écolo, plus
évidemment privilégié dans les communs
et ce que fait très bien la Zad Notrame
des Landes hein. Mais voilà, aller plus
loin, c'est c'est la Zague, la zone
autogouvernée où effectivement tu remets
en place des des systèmes de et de
gouvernance et de fonctionnement avec du
prix libre, avec des mandats révocables,
avec des élections sans candidat. Enfin,
il y a plein de techniques sociales qui
existent, qui sont magnifiques, que les
les gens connaissent mal et qui
permettent d'aboutir à une démocratie
quand même plus authentique que celle où
on est. Et en petit, surtout en petite
communauté, c'estàd pas prétendre gérer
67 millions de personnes, tu peux pas le
faire sans sans manipuler tout le monde.
La réalité, c'est que c'est quand tu
vois d'ailleurs au niveau tribal ou au
niveau des petites communautés, c'est
souvent 500 personnes, des communautés
qui fonctionnent bien, sur lequel il y a
démocratie directe.
Tu te rends compte que prêcher ça,
Ouais.
Euh le système en face, il peut pas
l'accepter parce que si tu fais des
petites communautés,
si euh tu utilises pas ta technologie
pour faire marcher comme un seul homme
toute une société de de plus de 60
millions d'habitants,
le système financier qui est basé sur
une fonction exponentielle, que le que
la dette est basée sur une fonction
exponentielle, tu te rends compte que de
prêcher ça, tu deviens un terroriste.
Oui, mais c'est ce qu' c'est ce qu'ils
essayent de voilà le moindre gilet
jaune, le moindre cassage de vitrine
alors que c'est dérisoire. Voilà.
Pourquoi
c'est des résort ? Parce que c'est une
attaque sur les biens quoi. C'estàd que
comment tu peux voilà accuser de
violence les gilets jaunes ou ces
mouvements ou les black block ?
Tu me fais une petite imitation de lait
à Sal à
Oui, je peux te faire ça. Ouais,
vas-y.
Mais monsieur Lamo, est-ce que vous
condamnez les violences ? Voilà, c'est
ça. Donc ça ça me fait hurler hein. Moi
ça me fait hurler complet. Euh pourquoi
? Parce que parce que sur la violence,
bon déjà il il y a une première
distinction à faire. Bon avon parle la
violence, je vais vous faire un petit
juste couplet là-dessus. Tu as violence
sur les biens, violence sur les
personnes, c'est la première temps.
Prends ton temps.
Ouais. Ouais. Voilà. Je m'énerve pas.
J'essaie de rester calme làdessus. Ça
m'énerve tellement que j'ai tendance à
être violent justement. Donc tu peux
attaquer les biens, d'accord ? Tu peux
attaquer les personnes. Vi sur les
biens, tu prends un marteau, tu casses
une vitrine, tu casses le fouquet, tu
mets le feu si tu veux, tu pètes un
abribus, tu pètes une banque. Bon, OK.
Ça fait mal à qui ? Tu vois ? Ça fait
mal à qui ? aux assureurs qui vont
devoir payer la vitrine si ton assurance
est pas bonne aux propriétaires qui sont
des banques ultra richissimes. Donc en
gros, tu attaques des symboles, tu tu
pénalises les symboles, c'est très bien.
Tu les obliges à dépenser de l'argent ce
qu'ils aiment pas. Donc ils sont obligés
de muter, ils sont obligés de changer.
Donc pour moi, c'est tout bénéf, c'est
tout tout est tout est positif
là-dedans. Voilà. De l'autre côté, tu as
la violence sur les personnes. Voilà qui
aujourd'hui fait la violence sur les
personnes. Qui blesse ? Qui mutile ? Qui
est borgne ? C'est les gilets jaunes,
c'est c'est les black block.
Bah non, j'ai j'ai pas connaissance d'un
black block qui est borné quelqu'un qui
qui fait perdre un pied à quelqu'un.
C'est la police française. Voilà.
Il y a eu des flics qui sont quand même
fait cartonner un peu. Il y en a un qui
s'est pris une pavasse.
Ouais. Ouais. C'est pris bien sûr mais
quand tu vois moi j'ai c'est ça si
m'avait frappé à la à l'azade parce que
pour la première fois je les voyais
vraiment très très près à Lazade ils
étaient là ils gardaient l'affaire sur
la ferm j'étais sur une journée deuxième
vague de de de d'invasion moi j'appelle
ça et j'étais j'étais sur la ferme de
Saint-Jean Luutertte et tu avais
vraiment donc tu les voyais très très
bien en plein soleil il crevai chaud les
pet machin et tu vois les protections en
fait tu as seul fa c'est derrière les
voilà c'est derrière les jambes mais
tout est archi protégé par du kevel ils
ont un matériel absolument délirant des
Donc qu'est-ce que tu veux leur faire
mal ? Même en faisant les jeux dire tu
regardes regarde les vidéos de 1968 sur
les manifes, regarde comment les flics
étaient étaient habillés et regarde
maintenant. Bon donc il y a un
accroissement du voilà du matériel qui
est qui est exponentiel donc ils sont
archi protégés. Donc il y a il y a
quasiment pas de blessés ou c'est
dérisoire quand Christophe d'été va
taper sur un gars on lui met 3 jours
d'arrêt. Mais 3 jours d'arrêt c'est que
dalle. Moi ça m'est arrivé de prendre
une bouteille. On m'avait mis 3 jours
d'arrêt. C'est c'est j'avais rien.
J'avais un éclat de verre là. Et bon.
Donc en réalité la violence sur les
personnes, elle est exercé par la police
sur son peuple aujourd'hui avec
évidemment le le la bénédiction et même
le la volonté du gouvernement macronien.
Donc tu parles de violence déjà, tu te
dis bon attends 22 éborniers, 5 amputés,
plus de 500 blessés tout ça c'est la
violence sur des personnes, donc la
vraie violence
et exercé de la police. Donc déjà
première chose
légitime la violence
la violence dit quand on dit que l'État
est le seul détenteur de la violence
légitime.
Oui mais non mais ça c'est c'est c'est
justement le problème quoi. C'est
qu'effectivement on considère que c'est
légitime. Eux ils born quelqu'un c'est
légitime. Ils sont jamais inquiétés
hein. Ils ont jamais été inquiétés là.
Donc ça c'est quand même absolument
scandaleux quoi. Bon voilà. Après en
plus sur les violences quand quand les
gens quand tu cadres une image où tu
vois des gens défoncer le fouquet, bon
tu es là, tu sélectionnes un segment. La
violence c'est toujours un processus.
C'est-à-dire que tu deviens pas violent
par hasard quoi. Tu vois, tu tu sors pas
exno devenant violent, quoi. C'est pas
une génération spontanée de violence
quoi. C'est des gens qui avant d'arriver
et te cramer le fouquet ont subi une
série de violence absolument délérante.
D'accord. Ils ont été rejetés dans je
sais pas combien d'entretiens à
l'embauche. Ils ont été discriminés
parce que ils sont blagu parce qu'ils
sont ils sont arabes et qu'ils arrivent
dans les trois derniers sélectionnés
puis qu'ils sont comme par hasard jamais
choisis dans les trois derniers parce
que bah ils ont voilà il parlent un peu
banlieu où ils sont donc tu as des
violences comme ça qui sont des
violences discriminatoires ou des
violences des fois sexistes. Tu as des
violences parce que tu es au chômage et
et et qu'on te donne de la merde et que
tu es obligé de te battre chaque mois
pour toucher tes indemisations parce
qu'on essaie de te sortir du système
d'assurance chômage dès qu'on peut.
Enfin, je pourrais te citer des tas de
choses quoi, tu vois, dans dans les
hôpitaux, dans les écoles, dans le donc
toutes ces violences sont mises en place
et à un moment donné, tu as la violence
aussi fiscale qui est qu'on taxe des
gens qui ont déjà du mal à s'en sortir
pendant que des des ultra riches, voilà,
ne sont imposés à hauteur de 5 % de leur
fortune, tu vois. Bon, donc ces
violences s'accumulant, à un moment
donné ça senté, ça s'accumule, ça se
sédimente et ça explose dans la rue, tu
vois.
Donc si tu regardes que la fin tu dis
mais qu'est-ce qu'ils ont ces black
block, c'est un scandaleux et cetera et
puis tu oublies toute la violence qu'ils
ont accumulé mais pendant des années,
c'est très souvent quoi. Tu vois qui a
été sédimenté, intériorisé et cetera, tu
vois. Et quand cette violence, elle ne
ressort pas dans la rue,
quand elle reste à l'intérieur des gens
qui tu aboutis à quoi ? Dépression,
suicide,
suicide, agression conjugale, c'estd que
tu tapes sur ton sur tes enfants, tu
tapes sur ta femme, tu tu vois. Voilà.
Donc pour moi, je le dis, c'est
extrêmement simple. C'est violence et
lieu. Mais même pour le gouvernement,
c'est une chance à la rigueur parce que
il y a pas meilleure façon de te
débarrasser de la violence que tu as
subi que de la sortir de toi et de la
défouler sur des biens. Voilà, c'est
certainement la façon la plus saine de
faire et celle qui te redonne en plus un
peu de légitimité intérieure, un peu de
fierté de toi-même un peu. Donc moi
quand je vois ces violences, les gens
ils sont horrifiés. Moi je moi
honnêtement je je vous dis franchement
je moi je trouve ça très bien. Je trouve
ça sain. Je trouve ça normal. Je trouve
ça absolument normal. Je trouve ça et je
suis même étonné qu'il y ait pas plus de
violence quoi. Tu vois le Baudriard, il
le disait, il avait une phrase
magnifique, il disait il disait "Mais
moi c'est pas la la violence qui me
surprend, c'est qu'il y a aussi peu de
violence quoi." Étant donné la violence
du système c'est c'est extrêmement
surprenant qu'il y a aussi peu de
violence en réaction quoi. Donc quand ça
sort un tout petit peu je me dis tiens
ils sont encore polis là.
Ah mais ils sont encore polis quoi. Moi
j'ai fait voilà, j'ai fait une nouvelle
là sur les gilets jaunes qui va sortir
dans le dans un recueil au diable vauver
où je montre différentes façons parce
que moi je je pense que s'agit pas faire
juste de la violence. Il s'agit pas non
plus de faire que des trucs bobo et mais
j'essaie de montrer ça s'appelle trois
nuances de jaune. Il y a une partie
fantastique et puis il y a deux parties
qui sont une bon je vais pas raconter
l'histoire, vous le lirez mais mais si
vous voulez il y a un moment donné où je
développe l'idée que
il faut créer des modes de lutte qui
soient les plus conviviaux, les plus
chaleureux possible qui fait que les
gens ont du plaisir à être ensemble, à
lutter ensemble. Et donc je développe
tout un truc sur la couleur jaune, sur
le fait de faire des marchés à prix
libre sur les ronds-points ou sur les
places des des euh des villes en faisant
un délire autour du jaune. C'estàdire
que tu ne vends que des fruits jaunes.
Donc tu vends que des bananes, des
citrons, des des pamplemous et cetera.
Puis après que des légumes jaunes, tu
vois des courges machin. Puis après les
gens viennent et puis font une buvette
et puis tu as que de la bière parce que
c'est jaune. Et puis tu boises pastisse
et puis après tu as les vendeurs d'huile
parce que c'est jaune aussi. Puis tu as
les marchands de fromage et puis tu tu
as les baraques à frites parce que c'est
jaune également et tout est jaune. Donc
tu as une sorte de rayonnement comme ça
jaune qui se met en place et qui donne
une espèce de de luminosité de de côté
solaire un peu des choses. Voilà, je
délire là-dessus mais en montrant que
bah oui, il y a des choses à faire qui
peuvent être sympas après sur des
carnavals, enfin je délire sur plein de
choses. Vous lirez le et puis il y a une
autre partie qui est une partie qui peut
apparaître comme du terrorisme. Moi,
j'appelle ça de l'errorisme ou en tout
cas du terrorisme extrêmement doux
puisqu'il y a pas de mort, il y a pas de
il y a pas de violence. Mais c'est le
moment où tu te dis
on a tout essayé démocratiquement, on a
fait je sais pas combien de manifes, on
a on essaie de créer des médias
indépendants, on fait des livres, on on
dit à quel point c'est scandaleux, on a
on a 70 % des Français qui sont opposés
à la politique de Macron, il devraient
déjà être destitués et cetera. Tout ça
n'est pas respecté. Donc à un moment
donné, ça veut dire que les gens qui
sont en poste, que ce soit les
milliardaires hein, qui gèrent
l'oligarchie actuelle ou euh ou le
gouvernement macronisque, qui sont que
les marionnettes et en tout cas que les
que les portes drapeau de cette
oligarchie-là, ces gens-là ne se sentent
pas menacés, ils se sentent pas
vulnérables, ils se sentent dans
l'impunité. Donc à un moment donné, il
faut faire quelque chose pour qu'ils
sortent de cette sensation d'impunité.
Voilà, je dis que ça mais sortir de
l'instation dans le je pour raconter la
fiction tant pis, on va me dire
assistitation à la violence si vous
voulez machin, je m'en fous.
Pas d'incitation à la violence.
Non mais c'est pas la citation la
violence, c'est incitation à la
réflexion incitation tu vois c'est qu'à
un moment donné bah tu prends tu prends
Bernard Arnaud, il a six gardes du
corps. C'est compliqué mais tu prends
quelqu'un qui est un peu moins protégé,
tu le mets dans un fourgon, tu l'amènes
au milieu d'une forêt dans le verrec si
tu veux loin de de tout.
Ouais. Ouais. C'est une fiction, on est
bien d'accord. Et tu le sors, tu le mets
au milieu de cette forêt là, tu le fous
à poil.
Et puis tu le laisses là, puis si tu
veux, tu discutes un peu avec lui, pas
qu'il soit trop tout seul. Tu lui parles
de politique sociale, justice fiscale et
cetera et tu laisses, tu vois, et il se
démerd quoi. Tu vois, il il se démerde
pour revenir retrouver une route à poil
l'hiver machin et ou alors tu largues à
5 km des côtes bretonne. C'est la
deuxième version, tu le fous dans l'eau,
tu lui mets une montte pour que voilà,
si tu vois qu'il flanche, tu vas le
récupérer pour pas qu'il crève, tu vois.
Mais tu tu voilà, tu l'obliges à faire
les 5 km pour rejoindre et à réfléchir
un petit peu. Tu vois, c'est qu'à un
moment donné, les gars, ils vont se dire
"Ah, on peut plus faire n'importe quoi."
C'estàdire, on a passé le seuil. C'est
que la violence qu'on exerce sur ces
gens-là, qu'on voyait pas et qu'on fait
tout pour pas voir parce qu'on est dans
nos bureaux, dans le plafond de verre et
cetera, elle est réelle et là on me la
restitue. Voilà, on me restitue cette
violence et on me la restitue
directement. Ce qui n'arrive pas
aujourd'hui c'estàd que la violence
qu'ils exercent, elle l'aurait jamais
restituée, tu vois. Et moi, je suis
désolé de dire ça, mais j'ai
l'impression que si à un moment donné,
tu passes pas et tu les fais pas se
sentir vulnérable, il y aura pas de
basculement, il y aura pas de changement
et on arrivera à rien quoi, tu vois.
Mais il faut coupler ça avec des vraies
luttes citoyennistes
positives, proposant des modes de vie
intéressants, proposant des modes de vie
chaleureux et conviviaux, mais aussi de
dire bah l'ennemi, à partir du moment où
l'ennemi il ne bouge pas, il ne change
pas, il continue à t'exploiter, il
continue à te mépriser, il continue à
t'humilier, il continue à exercer sa
violence systémique, ça c'est une
violence systémique
et ben à un moment donné il faut arrêter
de de d'être un pur bisouours quoi. Tu
peux pas quoi, tu vois. Je je voilà moi
en tout cas j'en suis à ce point-là
quoi, tu vois. Et c'est se dire voilà,
tu vois, je vais pas dire c'est pas
action directe, on va on va les prendre,
on va les buter, tu vois. Mais dans
action directe, il y avait cette logique
de dire
direct,
on fait une action directe. Tu sais
qu'action direct le le terme vient après
ils ont ils ont monopolisé ce terme,
mais l'action directe c'est une action
militante directe, on t'occupe un
bâtiment et il faut revenir à des à des
choses inventives de cet ordre-là quoi,
tu vois. Alors, est-ce que c'est des
patrons ? Est-ce que c'est le
gouvernement ? Parce que tu vois quand
on a enfoncé le le la grille de Benjamin
Grivveau, c'est bizarre mais Benjamin
Grivau là maintenant il va faire les
européennes tu vois. Il a plus eu trop
envie de
la mairie de Paris lui.
Si si. Ouais, il veut il veut il veut
pardon il veut postuler à la mairie de
Paris. Oui, bien sûr. Pardon. Ce
donc tu te dis tu vois on l'a su hein le
MDF il a commencé à péter les planss
après le le 8 décembre. Il a appelé en
disant lâche tout. Tu vois pourquoi ?
parce qu'ils sentent que ça y est, on
passe un stade de vulnérabilité et tant
qu'on passe pas ce stade là, voilà donc
moi je je voilà moi je suis juste un tu
vois, je suis juste un écrivain de SF,
je fais de la fiction voilà je suis pas
je suis pas un gourou, je suis pas un
politique, je suis pas voilà, je milite
mais en tant que citoyen. Tu as vendu
combien de livres ?
Simplement. Bah là sur les sur là, on
doit être à 300000 là aujourd'hui sur la
zone on doit être à je sais pas 100000
plus de 100000
voilà mais c'est voilà je suis un petit
auteur comme il y en a comme il y en a.
Tu payes tes impôts en France ?
Ouais bien sûr ouais puis je paye tout
en plus hein. Et puis pas des taux à 5 %
tu vois dès que tu passes des seuils, tu
payes tu payes bien quoi. Non non moi je
veux surtout pas voilà je je paye tout.
Je veux pas faire des fiscalisations, je
rate pas les défiscalisations machin. Je
trouve que c'est normal de payer. Ma ma
femme est prof, elle est payée par
voilà, elle est payé par l'État comme
beaucoup de travailleurs sociaux ou
d'éducation et donc voilà, c'est normal,
il faut payer ses impôts, il faut il
faut permettre aux gens de d'exercer.
Jérôme Cusac qui va pas faire de prison
autre que un bracelet un bracelet
électronique sur la côte Corse
euh condamné à quatre, deux fermes, deux
avec un un petit bracelet. C'est c'est
la justice des copains. C'est qu'est-ce
que
bah c'est c'est de toute façon enfin
faut que vous le faut vous le montrez
très bien. La justice c'est un rapport
de force, quoi. C'est-à-dire que c'est
euh c'est la façon dont dont les les
dominants, il dit quelque chose de très
beau, je trouve. Et quand il passe une
loi, il dit il définissent pas ce qui
est légal et illégal. Il gère les
illégalistes. C'est qu' ils définissent
déjà la façon dont tu vas pouvoir
contourner la loi. Voilà. Comment tu vas
pouvoir gérer l'illégalité pour que ça
passe, tu vois. Et dès les amendements,
dès la loi passée et cetera, les
amendements sont faits pour ça. Les
lobbyings travaillent là-dessus et il
passe des lois qui permettent de
contourner de façon intéressante. Donc
c'est une gestion de légalisme. Donc tu
peux pas attendre de la justice qu'elle
te sauve, tu vois. Tu peux pas attendre
de la justice qui qui est quelque chose
qui est créé par généralement par les
dominants. Qu'elle qu'elle qu' qu'elle
viennent faut pas avoir de naïveté
là-dessus. Voilà, c'est sûr. Tu vois, je
veux dire, un gars qui vole qui qui vole
100 € dans dans une épicerie, il est
attrapé, il va faire 3 mois fermes, tu
vois. et pas dans les conditions de de
KAC quoi. Donc quand tu vois Carlos Gonz
qui fraude un peu près je crois que
c'est 150 milliards de 150 millions non
pardon pas milliard pardon 150 millions
de de
Si tu parles en yenne c'est bon
ouais d'évasion fiscale.
Il il sera Heureusement qu'on a les
Japonais mais si tu fais ça en France
il sort le lendemain quoi.
Ah il a pas été encore condamné.
Présemption d'innocence.
Ouais ouais présemption d'innocence.
Voilà. Mais si tu veux, ils le savent et
et là c'est pareil. C'estàd que
l'impunité totale dont bénéficier ces
gens quand c'est s'ils font prendre la
main dans le pot de confiture de toute
façon ils vont payer une prime. Donc vu
tout ce qu'ils ont volé avant c'est pas
grave. Ce qu'il faudrait c'est les
coller vraiment 5 ans en prison ferme
et prendre tous leurs biens.
Et prendre tout leur bien. Non mais ça
serait la base quoi. Vraiment moi je
pense que vraiment Et là mais il suffit
de le faire une fois même hein. Tu fais
une fois ça valeur d'exemple pour tous
c'est ils ont pas envie de renoncer à
leur confort ces gens-là.
en pouvoir,
ah bah tu perds tout. Tu perds ton
pouvoir, tu perds ton confort, tu perds
l'argent, tu perds ton réseau
d'influence, tu perds tout. Donc si on
t'incarcèr 5 ans, tu le fais une ou deux
fois, ça suffit. Tous les patrons, tu
vas voir que l'évasion fiscale, elle va
Mais on le fait même pas, tu vois. Donc
le système est totalement perverti.
Ouais, c'est sûr.
Tu votes ? Ouais, ouais, je vote. Je
considère que c'est le plus bas niveau
de d'action politique, mais que ce plus
bas niveau, il on doit quand même le
faire, quoi. C'est-à-dire que voter une
fois tous les 5 ans, c'est un acte
dérisoire, ça te prend 5 minutes, euh ça
change quasiment rien parce que tout est
justement tout est tout est manipulé de
façon systémique.
Comment on fait pour
Mais mais quand même, il faut voter
parce que moi je considère que voilà,
c'est ça fait partie c'est un lac
politique quand même.
Comment on fait pour manipuler les gens,
pour leur faire voter ce qu'on veut et
comment on fait pour lever des légions
de castor ? Et la technique principale,
je trouve maintenant bon déjà tu parles
de la base que moi j'ai vu ce chiffre
récemment, c'est vraiment intéressant.
60 % des gens ne lisent jamais une
actualité politique ne s'intéresse
absolument pas à la politique, tu vois.
Donc quand on parle tous les deux, on
est déjà des gens surinformés qui lisent
énormément de politiques, qui savent ce
qui se passe et cort pour 60 % des gens,
il y a absolument aucune espèce
d'intérêt. Ils ne lisent aucun article
politique. Donc ces gens-là, ils vont
voter quand même. Donc il y en a
évidemment qui sont dans l'abstention,
mais sur ces 60 % là, il y a
certainement 30 % quand même qui qui
votent puisque le taux de l'abstention
présidentielle, je crois que ça doit
être 30 ou 35.
Donc ces gens-là vont voter. Comment ils
votent ? Tu vois, c'est on se pose pas
la question quoi. C'est ce fameux
Marais, c'est ce fameux Bah ces gens-là,
ils vont voter sur sur des sur des sur
des affects extrêmement simple quoi. La
gueule du candidat, sa jeunesse, sa
beauté,
euh ce qu'ils ont entendu à droite et à
gauche, mais de toute façon très
superficiel. C'est qu'ils lisent pas les
journaux, ils lisent les titres. Bon
et ce que tu vois en tout cas, c'est que
moi je prends toujours cet exemple parce
que ça me ça me rend fou. Tu prends
Macron mais c'était pareil sur Hollande,
j'avais vu les mêmes chiffres, c'était
pareil sur Sarkozi, les trois présents,
c'est la même chose. Quand ils viennent
d'être élus, il y a 2 tiers des Français
qui sont favorables au président. 2/3
c'estàd que ils disent voilà est-ce que
vous avez confiance de vos présidentes à
2 tiers même s'il y a que 52 % ou 50 bon
tiers tu fais le même sondage tout d'un
coup un an plus tard, un an et demi plus
tard, tu te retrouves à 1/ gros je te
fais grossièrement.
Donc il y a un tiers des Français, il y
a un français sur trois qui a voté qui
un an plus tard se réveille et se dit
"Mais c'est qui ce connard qu'on a élu à
la présidence de la République ?"
D'accord
Macron, si tu t'es informé, tu savais
exactement ce qu'il allait faire. Il l'a
dit, il l'a fait, il a pas trahi ses
promesses, il a vraiment fait ce qu'il a
dit. Tu savais d'où il venait, tu savais
qu'il était banquier. save que bon
donc ce tiers là c'est lui qui fait
l'élection
c'est lui qui fait passer Macron
et c'est lui le baiser puisque un an
après il dit "Mais attendez mais c'est
pas possible quoi." Tu vois voilà et ben
ce tir là il est il est il c'est ce tir
là qu'on manipule bah par voilà par les
médias et les médias qui sont qui sont
détenus. Macron c'est super intéressant.
Tu lis le le le bouquin de Branco,
comment il a été construit quoi. C'est
quelqu'un qui n'a absolument aucun
mérite d'accord. il est il est né d'une
autre famille. Euh il fait il fait les
grandes écoles de la République mais
parce qu'il est éduqué pour ça. Il rate
cinq fois les concours. Euh
il est tout à fait moyen. Euh il rentre
dans une banque, c'est un intrigant,
c'est plus ou moins séducteur. Euh bref
c'est un petit gars comme il y en a des
tonnes. Moi j'en ai vu des tonnes à les
sec des gens comme lui quoi. Rien que le
comportement, la façon de se comporter,
quand j'ai vu Macron, j'ai j'ai
l'impression de revenir à les secs et de
mes 3 ans. De petits connards arrogants
tête à claque. Tu as envie de gifler dès
que tu les vois. Enfin, c'est vraiment
des gens qui pour moi me sont
insupportables mais physiquement déjà,
tu vois, au départ. Et ce gars-là donc
sans sans talent particulier et ben il
faut lui construire un storytelling.
Voilà, c'est c'est là que c'est fort
maintenant. C'est-à-dire que comme les
gens vont pas lire les programmes, ce
tiers dont dont je parle ne lira pas les
programmes, n'ira pas voir les meetings,
regardera à peine les émissions
politisées. Au mieux, ils lisent Gala,
Paris Match et cetera dans chez les
coiffeurs et justement Gala, Paris Match
et cetera sont gérés par fameuse Mimi
Marchand, c'est-à-dire la responsable de
la de la presse people que que Macron a
a eu sous sa coupe grâce à Xavier Niel.
et elle va construire je sais pas, ils
disent à peu près 40 couvertures he
quand même sur 8 mois autour de ces de
cette pipolisation Brigitte Macron et
Emmanuel Macron. Et là tu as tu as un
storytelling qui est génial parce que
tuas tu as une femme âgée. Un homme
jeune et beau. Moi, je trouve pas beau
du tout. Ouais ouais. Enfin bon, plus
beaucoup plus âgé que lui. Un homme qui
est jugé beau, moi je trouve horrible
mais qui peut être considéré comme dans
les canons d'une d'une beauté de de
gendre idéal.
Donc ça fait triper les femmes depuis 40
ans 50 ans, tu vois. Ça fait un couple
un peu original. Donc on a un élément de
storytelling intéressant, le couple qui
s'aime, cette prof de théâtre français
qui l'a repéré, qui a vu que c'était
après tu as le deuxième storytelling qui
est le Mozart de la finance donc alors
que le gars bon, il a juste fait une
fusion acquisition comme on en fait des
des totes. Et tu bâtis voilà
storytelling. Donc il faut toujours dans
storytelling en tout cas faire croire
que
ce président est militant. C'était
pareil pour SarkoZi hein. Sarkozy qui
vient des Hautes familles et cetera,
c'éit un immigré hongois. Il s'était
fait tout seul. C'est un selfman là, il
s'est battu, il a échoué beaucoup en
politique mais il s'est battu. Il arrive
au bout de Et encore la rigueur Sarco
effectivement, il a fait un long chemin
pour arriver.
Le storytelling de de de François
Hollande, c'était on a un homme normal
ban
voilà, il a fait un régime mais il est
surtout il est banal, il est comme nous.
Il vous comprend parce qu'il est comme
nous. Tu sais en moi quand je fais de la
série télé et quand je fais des livres,
Aristote apprend une chose quand tu
bâtis un personnage et donc quand tu
fais du storytelling, c'est tu vas bâtir
un personnage, il faut que tu crées
l'identification au personnage donc au
président. Tu as deux façons de le
faire. Tu as deux grandes façons. Soit
tu fais l'identification par admiration,
on appelle ça par familiarité.
Voilà, tu connais ça. Voilà. Et donc bah
admiration c'est quoi ? C'est tu
présentes un personnage qui a des
qualités que tu aimerais avoir, qui te
fait rêver. Typiquement le super-héros.
Voilà.
Et puis par familiarité, c'est quelqu'un
qui est comme toi. Donc Hollande, il a
choisi l'identification par familiarité.
Ça marchait. C'est rare he que ça marche
he parce que généralement on fait par
admiration. Donc quand tu as un
quelqu'un qui n'a absolument rien fait,
qui n'a rien prouvé, qui qui est qui est
finalement assez médiocre dans le cadre
d'où il vient Macron, il faut inventer
les choses. Donc tu inventes des
expressions comme Mozart de la finance,
tu fais croire qu'il a été ultra
brillant, qu'il s'est fait tout seul et
cetera. alors qu'il a été entièrement
construit par ses euh par le soutien de
notamment Xavier Niel, Bernard Arnaud
euh donc des des des grands
milliardaires français quoi, tu vois,
qui l'ont construit, qui l'ont amené là
où il est et qui et qui ont préparé
toute la campagne médiatique pour le
porter avec ce storytelling de quelqu'un
qui s'est fait tout seul, qui a émergé
tout seul et puis qui a magnifique
couple avec Brigitte Macron et donc tu
bâtis un storytelling et c'est tout ce
que les gens vont retenir parce que
parce que l'intérêt d'un récit, c'est
qu'il favorise la mémorisation. Pourquoi
dans dans les espèces humaines, dans les
tribus, il y avait deux grandes choses
en littérature. C'est la poésie parce
que le la retour de la rime te permet de
mémoriser
le champ
et le champ bien sûr. Et tu as le récit
parce que le récit comme c'est une
conduite linéaire, si on te raconte une
histoire, tu vas retenir beaucoup mieux
l'histoire que si on te raconte un
programme politique avec des thèmes. Tu
vois si je vous raconte une anecdote,
vous allez retenir l'anecdote alors que
je vous ai théorisé un truc très
compliqué que vous allez pas retenir.
Donc quand tu as un président qui se se
présente, il faut créer cette toute
petite ligne narrative qui est
généralement très simple. Tu vois
l'émigré enroit qui a réussi, qui s'est
fait tout seul, le Mozard de la finance
ultra brillant, qui a réussi tous les
concours de la République et qui a cette
magnifique histoire d'amour avec sa
femme plus âgée que lui. Et ça suffit à
passer, tu vois. Tu as pas besoin de
faire beaucoup plus quoi. C'est puisque
les gens vont pas aller chercher
l'information, vont pas vont pas
détailler les programmes. Il y avait pas
de programme de toute façon Macron il a
il a fait le programme tout à la fin. Il
sait que ça sert à rien. C'est c'est pas
avec ça qu'il va gagner, tu vois. Donc
tu tu connais la chaîne, notre chaîne ?
Ouais.
Tuas tu as vu quoi de de ce qu'on a pu
produire ? J'ai vu Stigler que j'adore
que je trouvais extraordinaire sur
l'analyse des technologies. Ben j'ai vu
Sniderman qui qui montre justement
comment fonctionne le journalisme
aujourd'hui en France. J'ai vu les deux
les deux les deux très très bons SVW de
Ran Branco. C'est tout le premier que
j'avais adoré. J'ai vu celui de Begodo.
Ouais, j'en ai vu un certain nombre.
On va parler de ton bouquin un peu
maintenant.
Ouais. Ouais. Ouais. C'est vrai. Parce
que
Comment il s'appelle les furtifs ?
Les furtifs,
pourquoi les furtifs ? C'est quoi
?
C'est une petite bête qu'on chasse.
Ouais, c'est des êtres. Donc c'est des
dans le livre donc ça se passe en 2040,
c'est en France dystopie ultralibérale
justement où les villes ont été ont été
ont été rachetées. Toutes les villes
intéressantes ont été rachetées par des
par multinationales parce qu'elles
avaient emprêté sur le marché bancaire
international et sont tombés en faillite
donc ce qui permettait au aux
multinationales de les racheter et
toutes les villes intéressantes. Donc
par exemple Paris a été racheté par LVMH
parce que c'est la ville du luxe. Cann a
été racheté par la Warner parce que
c'est la ville du cinéma. Lyon est
racheté par Nesley parce que c'est la
capitale de la gastronomie. Donc ça
s'appelle Nest Lyon et puis voilà, ça se
passe à Orange qui a été racheté
évidemment par Orange
parce qu'ils avaient pas payé la marque
donc c'était c'était plus intéressant
pour eux. Et dans ces villes-là, tu
payes plus d'impôt parce que c'est voilà
principe ultra bilébral. Donc tu tu as
des forfaits, tu as un forfait
privilège, premium ou standard. Si tu es
standard, ben tu as accès en gros à 50 %
des rues de la ville, les avenues de la
ville, des squir de la ville, des parcs
de la ville. Donc tu te galères dans les
embouteillages, tu vas dans les squir
qui sont bondés d'enfants pauvres parce
qu'ils sont comme toi. Et quand tu as un
forfait privilège, tu as accès à 100 %
de tout. Donc tu passes par les avenues
où où les autres n'ont pas le droit de
d'aller parce que évidemment tu as ta
bague hein, chacun chaque citoyen a une
bague et cette bague elle est
géolocalisée. Donc si tu rentre dans les
dans les zones interdites, bah
automatiquement tu as des amendes qui
sont décaissées automatiquement sur ta
bague. Au pire si tu insistes tu as des
drones qui viennent te te voir. Donc
voilà, tu es dans ce monde-là et dans ce
monde là qui est donc aussi hyper tracé,
hyper tu as des êtres qu'on a découvert
que l'armée a découvert qui s'appelle
les furtifs. Donc ils sont des êtres
vivants à la fois végétaux, minéraux,
animaux quoi qui sont un peu à la
croisée des règnes comme ça et qui ont
la capacité de métamorphose permanente
et qui vivent dans l'angle mort de la
vision humaine. C'est qu'ils sont là
depuis on se rend compte qu'ils sont là
depuis des centaines millions de
millions d'années. Ils ont développé
cette faculté furtive de se placer
toujours à l'endroit où tu regardes pas.
Par là s'ils étaient dans c ce studio,
ils seraient derrière le il serait dans
le coin du plafond là on regarde pas ou
derrière ma chaise ou et pour moi c'est
la plus haute forme du vivant. Voilà.
Moi ce qui m'intéresse, c'est de c'est
de travailler là-dessus.
C'est qu'est-ce que ça veut dire être
vivant et qu'est-ce que c'est les plus
hautes formes possibles du vivant. Donc
c'est l'incarnation de ça et évidemment
c'est l'envers de la société de trace et
de contrôle puisqu'il ne laisse jamais
de trace et puisqu'on peut pas les
localiser, les repérer et qu'ils
échappent toujours à la à la vision
humaine, sauf les rares fois où tu peux
par miracle les voir et dans ce cas-là,
ils se figeent, il se céramifie à très
haute température, il se fichent dans
une forme qui n'est pas analysable par
les scientifiques et qui fait que
l'espèce ne peut pas être
redupliquée, comprise, dévoilée.
Donc c'est une sorte de syndrome de la
gorgonne, j'appelle ça. Voilà. Donc
c'est ce ce monde là. Et dans ce monde
là tout simplement l'histoire, elle est
très simple. C'est c'est un père qui
part à la recherche de sa fille qui est
parti avec les furtifs quoi. Et qui
devient chasseur de furtif pour essayer
de la
ou
de la retrouver.
Si je te dis la force de surgir et l'art
de disparaître ou si je te dis la force
de disparaître et l'art de surgir.
Ah c'est beau ça.
Toi ?
Ah bon ? C'est c'est c'est bien
j'écris bien. Euh c'est marrant, ça me
fait penser à la la fusis des des Grecs,
ce que ce qui a donné le mot physique et
nature. Il dit ça, c'est l'art de
l'éclosion. C'est c'est tout d'un coup
quelque chose est clos qu'on attendait
pas, auquel on Ça je trouve ça très
beau.
Un signe noir.
Ouais, un signe noir. Le fameux signe
noir qui qui qui est le logo Tinkerview.
Au début, je j'avais j'avais pas compris
d'ailleurs. Donc, j'ai été voir, je me
suis renseigné et ouais, je trouve ça
très intéressant cette idée de de tout
d'un coup un surgissement très très
puissant, complètement inattendu et qui
modifie tout quoi qui et là c'est le cas
c'estàd que le surgissement des furtifs
dans la révélation de l'existence des
furtifs crée crée un phénomène
totalement révolutionnaire et
insurrectionnel dans dans la société
quoi. Et on va vers ce que moi j'appelle
du zoop punk tu vois. avant c'était le
Cyberpunk c'est le le délire de la SF
pendant longtemps a été de dire en se
couplant avec les machines, en se
s'articulant avec les machines, en
s'augmentant avec les machines, on va
atteindre un stade d'émancipation ou de
ou de libération qui peut être
passionnant. Ça a été longtemps le je
dirais le paradigme en SF et l'espèce de
ligne de fuite de désir de la SF qui a
culminé avec le le transhumanisme. Et je
crois qu'il y a un basculement et moi je
mon livre je pense fait partie de ce
basculement où on va revenir à une façon
de renouer avec le vivant. C'est-à-dire
que c'est le couplage avec le vivant,
retrouver des hybridations avec le
vivant. Donc zop, biopk, je sais pas
comment on peut appeler ça qui qui voilà
qui est peut-être la nouvelle et ça et
ça va avec les les courants écologiques
actuels aussi qui sont des courants qui
essayent de se réinsérer dans de
réinsérer l'homme dans le tissu du
vivant et et de recomendre qu'on fait
partie de cette immense sphère du
vivant, qu'on arrête de la piller, de
l'exploiter, de l'extraire, de
un peu tout ça. Voilà, les furtifs.
Ouais, c'est un peu
Si si tu devais laisser un conseil pour
les jeunes générations. Wouh
! Toujours toujours très difficile ça.
Euh
la mer.
Ouais, je crois. Bon, déjà première
chose c'est que
tu la connais cette question. Oui oui
oui. Et et c'est c'est intéressant de la
poser et en même temps c'est faut faut
toujours s'en méfier quand on est nous
le la personne qui doit le
parce que dès que tu as une petite
position publique ou une petite position
euh
où les gens t'écoutent ou te lisent ou
euh ou regardent tes films et cetera, on
va avoir tendance à te demander euh
voilà des pistes ou de porter
des valeurs. Bon moi voilà, j'ai j'ai
envie de dire OK, je peux vous donner
des pistes, mais évidemment le travail
et d'émancipation et de libération et de
réflexion, c'est toujours aux gens de le
faire. Et je pense que le roman pour ça
est quelque chose de
de fabuleux parce que c'est un art où tu
ouvres le crâne des gens, tu leur
imposes pas les choses, tu leur permets
de de de passer par des affects, des
percepts, des concepts très très
intéressants, mais tu fermes rien. En
tout cas, moi j'essaie de de rien
fermer. Donc le conseil que je donnerai
aux nouvelles génération malgré tout ça,
une fois que j'ai dit tout ça,
jeune génération.
Ouais. Jeune génération. Moi j'ai un
public en plus qui qui qui est jeune et
ça c'est c'est un vrai bonheur de de
découvrir ça. C'està-dire que je sais
pas si c'est l'énergie de mes livres, je
sais pas si c'est le côté optimiste ou
positif de que j'essaie de porter dans
mes livres qui fait ça. Mais en tout
cas, il y a j'ai un public très jeune
qui vient qui vient à la table qui vient
cassé qui et ça c'est super. C'est super
parce que je trouve que c'est à eux
qu'on doit s'adresser d'abord. C'est eux
qui vont changer le monde. C'est plus
nous. Moi, j'ai 49 ans, je vais
continuer à me battre, mais je dirais
que je suis déjà sur la mauvaise
mauvaise passe.
Moi, j'ai envie de leur dire
un méfiez-vous à blog du technococon.
Voilà, on vous a accouché, vous êtes
accouché dans le technocon, vous êtes la
génération digitale, vous êtes la
génération qui est née avec internet,
qui est née avec tous ces outils. Ces
outils sont extraordinaires pour
accroître votre pouvoir sur le monde,
pour faire faire aux machines des
choses. Mais oubliez jamais que tout
accroissement de pouvoir peut se payer
d'un déficit de puissance ou d'un
approvisement de votre puissance. Si tu
définis la puissance par la capacité de
faire toi-même les choses, quoi,
vraiment, de faire toi-même les choses
avec tes capacités cognitives, ta
mémoire, ton imagination, ta capacité de
création, ton corps et cetera. Donc de
se dire attention quand on vous propose
un pouvoir technologique, on vous
propose que de déléguer à la machine,
d'externaliser vers la machine, vers
l'appli, vers le logiciel des choses que
vous pourriez peut-être faire vous-même.
Posez-vous la question de ce que ça vous
appauvrit en terme de puissance parce
que c'est vos puissances personnelles
qui vont vous libérer. C'est vos
puissances personnelles qui vont faire
de vous quelque chose de de d'heureux,
d'émancipé, de de qui vont vous faire
atteindre aussi une forme de joie, de
bonheur. C'est parce que vous allez
utiliser ces puissances qui sont en haut
et vous allez vous battre avec elle. Si
vous déléguez, si vous externalisez, si
vous cédez à cette espèce de voilà de
pente naturelle mais qui descend,
ce fameux Nge, le petit coup de pouce
qu'on te donne pour aller vers la
facilité, si tu cèdes à ça, euh tu
t'autoaliennes tout seul. Voilà, c'est
c'est moi je mon grand délire dans les
dans les dans les furtifs, c'est ça.
C'est un moment donné, je définis une
espèce de de jeu de mot complètement
fou, un peu débile mais que je trouve
finalement assez assez fort. Je dis
voilà, on est dans le self service,
c'est-à-dire que le ser tu l'écrit SF
quoi, c'est-à-dire dans l'autoservage de
l'autoalénation. C'est le vis de
l'autoalénation. Et aujourd'hui, les
gafas par exemple mettent en place un
ensemble d'outils qui vont maximiser ta
capacité à t'autoer. Il t'impose rien en
fait. En réalité, personne te met un
flingue sur la tente. Personne te tuas
juste avec un lanceur de balle quoi. Tu
vois, ces outils, on te les met à
disposition. Mais ces outils, si tu fais
pas gaffe, ils vont te permettre
d'optimiser l'autoaliénation que tu vas
tu vas créer sur sur toi-même, tu vois.
Et c'est la force de ce système- làà,
c'est qu'on arrive à un moment où c'est
même plus le contrôle, c'est même plus
la trace, c'est que tu vas toi-même
emploigner les outils qui
t'autoaliennent parce que on te vend de
la commodité, on te vendre la loi du
moindre effort, on outit tes peurs, tu
vois, on conjure tes tes tes peurs, on
conjure tes angoisses avec toute cette
bulle quoi, d'outil autour de toi. Donc
moi, j'ai envie de dire voilà, soyez
soyez conscient de ça, soyez très
conscient de ça. N'hésitez pas à aller
vers le dehors, n'hésitez pas à déchirer
le techno concours, n'hésitez pas à
aller vers l'altérité, c'est aller vers
des gens qui sont pas comme vous, qui
pensent pas qu'on vous qu' on pas votre
couleur de peau, alleer dans les pays
étrangers, allez vous confronter, allez
voir la Zad ce qui se passe, allez voir
tout un ensemble de gens qui font pas
partie de votre communauté, continuez à
vous confronter à ce qui n'est pas vous
quoi. Voilà, sortez des familiarités et
c'est là que vous allez grandir, c'est
là que vous allez devenir plus noble. Ça
va croître le le le volume intérieur de
ce que vous êtes. Voilà. Moi je pense
que c'est ça. Il faut constamment aller
aller essayer d'ouvrir le le ce volume
intérieur et les sortir de sa zone de
confort.
Ouais. Ouais. Ouais.
Alors, question d'internet parce que on
t'a pas fait les questions internet.
Alors, qu'est-ce que vous répondez aux
gens qui disent "Au moi, j'ai rien à
cacher".
Ah, ça c'est terrible. Ça c'est
terrible. Il faudrait faire un bouquin
juste pour répondre à ça quoi. Bon, des
bon ça c'est une absurdité totale. Il
faut vraiment c'est comme les gens qui
disent "Non, mais la technologie c'est
neutre, tout dépend ce qu'on en fait."
Bon, ça c'est complètement aberrant.
Bon, la première chose pour moi c'est un
vrai délit de solidarité de dire ça.
C'estd que il se peut que toi
aujourd'hui dans la société où tu es et
un momenté he parce que c'est toujours
un momenté, tu n'es rien à cacher. Mais
dis-toi que la personne qui qui est ton
pote, ta mère, peut-être ton fils,
peut-être n'importe qui, ton patron,
quelqu'un que tu aimes bien et cetera,
il est peut-être homosexuel, il est
peut-être juif, il est peut-être
handicapé, il pardon,
il a peut-être le sida,
il a peut-être le sida et cetera. et lui
il a peut-être des choses à cacher,
quoi. Et si toi tu as rien à cacher, ça
veut dire que tu le laisses lui
s'exposer à la lumière et tu le laisses
souffrir du panneoptique et tu lui
laisses dans sa merde avec la
possibilité qu'on le discrimine à cause
de ce qu'il pense, à cause de sa
sexualité, à cause du fait qu'il est
trans, à cause du fait qu'il est noir
avec il y a 1000 raisons pour lesquelles
on peut discriminer quelqu'un dans 1000
types de gouvernement possible quoi.
Donc toi, tu as peut-être rien à cacher,
mais dire ça, c'est que tu es un [__]
d'égoïste, quoi. Et que tu penses pas à
tous les gens qui peuvent avoir quelque
chose à cacher et qui doivent laisser
les choses cacher parce que c'est leur
vie privée quoi. Et la deuxième chose,
c'est que tu peux ne pas avoir quelque
chose à cacher. Aujourd'hui, en 2019 en
France, et encore ça se discute
vraiment, mais peut-être qu'en 2027,
quand Marion Maréchal Le Pen sera élu,
là, tu vas te retrouver alors que tu
pensais pas avec beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à cacher, quoi. Voilà. Et ça, tu
l'avais pas compris, tu l'avais pas
anticipé parce que tu es juste le nez
sur ton époque et et en croyant vivre en
en démocratie. Donc ça c'est quand même
Ouais. Ouais. C'est quand même
hallucinant. Et puis même sur le fond
ontologiquement, je pense qu'on a
toujours quelque chose à cacher au sens
où voilà, on a des choses extrêmement
intimes, un secret, des choses
extrêmement intimes de sa famille, de sa
vie, de sa sexualité,
voilà. Et ces choses-là, il faut il faut
pouvoir les protéger. C'est c'est le
droit le plus élémentaire de pouvoir
protéger les choses que tu considères
comme extrêmement précieuses quoi parce
que c'est ta vie quoi.
Alors autre question internet. Comment
se rééduquer et arrêter d'utiliser le
contrôle horizontal ?
Ouais, ça c'est une belle question hein.
Ça c'est une très belle question quoi.
C'est une très belle question parce
qu'elle est corrélée à l'incertitude, à
l'acceptation de l'incertitude quoi.
C'est-à-dire que il faut que tu acceptes
que tu ne sais pas que tu sais pas ce
que l'autre fait, que tu sais pas si si
ta femme te trompe, que tu sais pas ce
que ta fille si elle fume du si elle
snif de la cocaïne ou pas et que et qu'à
un moment donné il faut accepter de pas
le savoir quoi. Et ça c'est une
magnifique démonstration de liberté que
tu fais et c'est un magnifique don de
liberté que tu fais à tes proches si tu
leur fais confiance.
Ouais, tu leur fais confiance et même
sans leur faire confiance, tu leur
laisses la liberté. Peut-être qu'elle de
la cocaïne, OK, c'est son choix, c'est
sa liberté, elle peut le faire quoi, tu
vois ? Et c'est un vrai nom que tu fais
aux gens. Donc ça c'est une façon de
conjurer. Mais c'est de l'éthique hein,
c'est vraiment ça relève pour l'éthique.
Ouais.
Alors, autre questionnet brut.
L'espionnage du big data. Alors, je
dirais l'espionnage par le big data
est-il le même par les Américains et par
les Chinois ? Pas d'interrogation. Ça
j'en sais absolument rien. Je sais pas.
OK.
Je pense que la NSA est quand même très
puissante mais je pense que les Chinois
ont rien à env
la chinoise.
Tu vois le délire.
Autre autre question internet. Quand
est-ce que le regard sur la surveillance
a changé ? Depuis quand est-ce
acceptable de regarder le téléphone de
sa copine ?
Ouais, c'est très intéressant. C'est
c'est Je pense qu'il y a des il y a des
moments de basculement mais qu'on voit
pas. C'est fait partie de ces micro
événements, de ces micro modification
sociétale qu'on voit pas. Il y a
énormément de de je crois qu'on peut
plus compter le nombre de couvertures
qu'il y a sur on est tous fichés, il y a
plus de vie privée et cetera. Ça devient
même une espèce de maronnier de la
presse quoi. Très régulièrement ça
revient. À quel moment c'est devenu
acceptable ? J'en sais rien mais en tout
cas c'est acclimaté. Ouais aujourd'hui
une question. Comment tu gères l'éthique
dans dans tes livres ?
l'éthique autour de la science, autour
de la technologie. Euh
est-ce que toi-même tu as une éthique ?
Ouais, bien sûr, mais tu tu la gères par
tes personnages. Moi, j'ai j'ai des des
romans qui sont des romans
polyphoniques, c'estàd qu'ù il y a euh
souvent 6 7 h personnages qui
s'expriment à la première personne et
qui portent chacun une vision du monde
qui est souvent différente, variée, même
si ça fait une sorte de constellation
qui peut-être est relativement homogène
au final, mais et chacun de ces
personnages par leur comportement, c'est
ce que l'éthique, elle se fait dans les
actes, dans les dans un roman. C'est la
façon dont agissent mes personnages qui
définissent le leur éthique et qui et
qui portent les valeurs que j'ai envie
de porter quoi. Donc euh
question d'internet
1984 points d'interrogation le meilleur
des mondes V pour vant d'état minority
report bienvenue à Gataka.
Ouais
ou le tout à la fois
ouais je dirais tout à la fois quand
même. Et il oublie Matrix là non
il oublé Matrix.
Ouais Matrix quand même. Matrix c'est
quand même une des meilleures lectures
métaphoriques de de la société quand
même je trouve.
Je dirais bienvenue à Daka, on y est pas
encore mais même si on a on n pas loin
Laurent Alexandre quand même séquence le
génome donc on peut on peut s'attendre à
ce que ça arrive. Mais meilleur des
mondes bien mieux que 84 en réalité on
est beaucoup plus proche du meilleur des
pour moi le meilleur des mondes est
beaucoup plus juste dans l'anticipation
finalement que 84.
Euh vous pensez quoi de la SF japonaise
? Ghostin the Shell Akira ?
Ouais c'est super.
Moi je trouve que pour moi Ghost in the
Shell c'est le premier grand mythe
contemporain qu'on ait eu. A
une p il y a une pure un pur son avec.
Oh là là, c'est magique. Mais parce que
c'est la première fois qu'on a dit que
dans l'océan d'information dans lequel
on baignait pouvait émerger
un être qui s'autocrée quoi, qui s'auto
voilà qui s'auto qui se sort lui-même de
l'océan d'information doté de toutes les
capacités que cet océan d'information a
pu créer et qu'avec ce et et que le rêve
de de cet être là, c'est de s'incarner.
c'est de de de trouver la chair quoi. Et
ça c'est génial pour nous quoi. Tu vois
c'est pur d'information et son rêve
c'est de s'incarner quoi, tu vois. Et ça
ce mythe là il est il est magnifique. Je
trouve c'est un des rares mythes
modernes qu'on a. On a pas beaucoup des
mythes modernes. Celui-là est un vrai
mythe moderne.
Autre question d'internet. Comment
essayez-vous par vos histoires de
transformer notre regard du monde, notre
manière de regarder la technologie ?
Est-ce que vous essayez de faire passer
des messages ?
Oui, bien sûr. Ouais. Enfin, je pense
que si tu si tu lis mes trois livres,
c'est très clair. C'est de la vraie
enfin pour moi, c'est vraiment la
littérature engagée. Sans être bourine,
je pense, sans être sans être donneuse
de leçon. En tout cas, j'essaie de
vraiment plus l'être. Et euh
moi je trouve que à partir du moment où
tu as à partir du moment où tu es élu, à
partir du moment où tu as une
responsabilité publique, ne pas porter
de valeur, c'est c'est criminel. Enfin,
tu vois, si tu portes pas de valeur, bah
ça veut dire que tu cautionnes celle qui
existe, quoi. Si tu penses que le
système va bien, bah oui, continue à
faire des livres, des des romans d'amour
qui se passent à Saint-Germain des Prè,
tu vois, en 2019. Mais mais si tu
considères qu'il faut changer quelque
chose dans cette société, la moindre des
choses, c'est de le mettre en scène dans
dans t dans tes romans, quoi. C'est de
le mettre en récit, c'est de le mettre
en affect, c'est c'est de créer des
personnages qui se battent, c'est de
montrer les résistances, c'est
d'imaginer des brèches, d'imaginer des
fictions positives et et et de donner
envie, enfin d'être une machine de désir
quoi. Moi je dis des fois voilà, c'est
quand tu rentres dans dans un livre, moi
mon mon rêve c'est que quelqu'un qui
rentre dans un livre et qui sort au bout
des 700 pages, il s'est opéré une
transformation d'énergie quoi.
C'est-à-dire que si quelqu'un me dit
"Putain, ça m'a donné la pêche ton
livre, pour moi, j'ai gagné." Voilà, tu
vois. Après, il peut me dire "Le style
fabuleux, c'est poétique, tes
personnages les adore." Très bien, ça va
me faire plaisir. Mais vraiment, la
chose la plus importante, c'est ça m'a
donné l'énergie. Voilà, ça m'a donné
l'énergie, ça m'a donné envie de vivre,
ça m'a donné envie de me battre, ça m'a
donné envie de changer ce système, ça
m'a donné envie d'être heureux, ça m'a
donné envie de m'émanciper, de me
libérer. Si ça ça fait ça, si le livre
opère cette transformation d'énergie,
alors c'est gagné quoi. Voilà. Et elle
s'opérera de façon très différente selon
les gens, tu vois. Mais mais c'est le
but de l'art pour moi. En tout cas, un
des buts principals de l'art, c'est
d'être un transformateur d'énergie. Si
tu veux voir un film et que tu ressors
intact en sortant, tu as perdu ton temps
d'aller voir ce film là quoi. Si tu vois
une série télé que tu ça fait juste te
divertir et que tu ressors et que tu as
pas un surcroix d'énergie, tu te sens
pas un peu plus vaste, tu te sens pas un
peu plus grande, tu sens pas un peu plus
volumique, tu as pas un peu plus
d'énergie ? Bah c'est c'est clair ne
sert à rien. Voilà. Donc euh
question internet. Comment
réfléchissez-vous à la place des femmes
dans vos romans ?
Ouais, ça c'est des questions qu'on me
pose souvent. Euh au départ, j'y
réfléchissais pas. Le premier roman à la
zone dehors, écrit à 22 ans entre 22 25
ans, je j'étais l'héritier moi d'une
famille assez patriarcale. Mon père
c'est costaud, assez macho et cetera.
Donc j'ai j'héritais de ça. Mon
personnage féminin qui qui est très beau
qui est un personnage super positif qui
est une sorte d'incarnation de la
vitalité qui s'appelle Boule de chat, il
est vu uniquement à travers le fantasme
et le désir du du personnage principal.
Donc donc le personnage féminin est
existe pas beaucoup et on peut vraiment
considérer que c'est pas un grand livre
féministe, tu vois. En tout cas, ça
reste un livre très très masculiniste.
Puis progressivement, ben en
grandissant, je me suis ouvert, j'ai
j'ai rencontré aussi des filles, plus de
filles. Je me suis euh ma part féminine
aussi a a grandi et euh et là, je crois
que le troisème est vraiment un beau
livre un beau livre sur ce cet aspect là
parce que j'ai vraiment quatre
personnages féminins qui sont chacune
dans leur domaine
vraiment des des des superbes, je trouve
moi des superb persos quoi. Voilà, qui
sont même plus intéressants que les
persos masculins. Le livre dédié à une
femme ?
Ouais. À trois femmes même puisque c'est
dédié à ma femme et à mes à mes deux
filles quoi. Moi voilà, je suis au
milieu de trois filles. Donc ça aussi ça
m'a beaucoup évidemment beaucoup changé.
Puis moi je suis avec une féministe
depuis 14 ans. Donc je m'en prends plein
la gueule constamment quoi. Donc sur ces
thèmes là donc ça m'a fait aussi
énormément changer. Mais moi je viens de
loin. Voilà, je viens de d'un modèle qui
était qui était très batarcal et que
j'avais pas j'avais pas interrogé quoi,
tu vois. Donc j'ai fait le chemin. Je
trouve que c'est pas mal. Bien sûr, je
suis encore loin de de du féminisme
parfait. Et
encore deux trois encore deux trois
questions internet. Quelle importance du
jeu vidéo dans la politique ?
C'est intéressant. Euh nous on a essayé
de faire un jeu vidéo. Voilà R B qui
était enfin l'ambition était de faire un
jeu vidéo politique justement sur ce de
trace. C'est très difficile en fait
parce que tout médium le jeu vidéo le le
cœur du médium c'est le gameplay. C'est
les mécaniques de jeu. C'est les
mécaniques de jeu qui transmettent la
sensation. Et c'est très compliqué de
faire un mécanique de jeu qui soit
politique. Tu peux faire un décor
politique, tu peux faire un lumière
narratif politique, tu peux faire des
personnages politiques, mais ce qui va
rester concrètement dans le joueur,
c'est son c'est le gameplay, tu vois. Et
c'est très compliqué de de transmettre
un affect.
Il y a un exemple qui est très connu et
qui est génial, c'est l'exemple de Ico
qui est un jeu euh euh où tu tiens une
princesse, tu dois tu dois le sortir une
princesse d'un d'un d'espèce de de
forteresse et et si tu la lâches euh tu
perds. C'est-à-dire que tu dois toujours
tenir la princesse et et ce jeu te te
crée vraiment l'affect du lien.
C'est-à-dire que quand tu joues, tu
comprends ce que ça veut dire d'être lié
à quelqu'un et de pas lâcher quelqu'un
et de jamais le lâcher. Mais parce que
le gameplay est corrélé au fait de la
tenir et de toujours la prendre avec
toi. Tu vois, c'est le gameplay qui crée
la notion de lien et qui te fait sortir
avec cette notion de lien. Mais si tu as
pas un gameplay qui est capable de créer
un affect, tu tu peux rien transmettre.
Nous l'affaire, moi je te dis, je quand
je suis rentré dans le jeu vidéo, j'ai
eu 3 ans, je me suis dit je vais faire
un jeu vidéo hyper politique, vous allez
voir ce que vous allez voir. Je vais
porter toutes les valeurs auxquelles je
crois. Ça va être révolutionnaire
machin. Au final, que dalle ou très peu
de choses parce que oui, la narration
est révolutionnaire, oui, l'histoire est
révolutionnaire, oui, mais en réalité,
le gameplay du ce qu'on appelle du mêlé
combat, c'est du combat, c'est ce qu'on
appelle du travers escalad et il y a un
tout petit gameplay un peu politique qui
est le mémoire remix. tu remixes la
mémoire des gens pour qu'il change de
comportement. C'est 10 % du jeu. Et ben
ça marche pas. Ça véhicule pas de
l'intérieur par le gameplay le Donc
c'est très compliqué de faire des jeux
politiques. Il y en a il y en a qui
existent.
Ton ton jeu vidéo préféré c'était quoi
le truc qui t'a le plus marqué ?
Moi je suis pas du tout un joueur tu
vois. Déjà
jamais entendu parler mankind.
Non non.
Starcraft.
Starcraft oui. Ouais je connais mais bon
voilà. Moi je joue très peu. J'ai une
console mais je console
j'ai une PS3. Ouais que j'ai acheté au
moment où j'ai fait où j'ai fait le R M
où j'ai je suis rentré je là il m'a dit
faut que tu faut que tu a une console
faut que tu joues. En réalité j'ai très
peu joué parce que je jouais plus avant
jou à Doom des trucs comme ça des trucs
super bourins. Moi j'étais vraiment dans
le jeu de divertissement mais dans le
jeu même de défoulement. Moi en réalité
le jeu auquel j'ai plus joué c'est les
jeux de combat euh
sur le calibur. Wou
voilà quand même quand même. Et je
jouais en arcade. Jouis je jouais pas
mal en arcade. Et pourquoi ? Parce que
pour moi l'affect dominant du jeu
c'était le défoulement d'une sorte de
violence intérieure de colleur intérieur
et ça m'aidait à défouler ça quoi. Et ça
reste le cas des fois je rejoue la seule
calibure pour me défouler quoi. Et je
reconnais voilà c'est un affect que j'ai
besoin des fois de sortir. Ça m'évite de
de casser la gueule d'un flic peut-être
je sais pas mais en tout cas ça me donc
je suis beaucoup jeux de combat un peu
les jeux de foot parce que j'adore le
foot mais sinon
autre question internet. Est-ce que vous
êtes décroissant et ça veut dire quoi
pour vous ?
Ouais belle question. Euh oui, je suis
décroissant. Voilà. Enfin, j'essaie en
tout cas de l'être.
Euh c'est quand même voilà ça ça c'est
c'est quand même compliqué hein, tu
vois. Voilà. Tu
mange la viande ?
Je mange de la viande. Euh j'en mange
beaucoup trop euh parce que j'adore la
viande. On m'a demandé mon plat préféré
l'autre fois. J'ai dit côte de bœuf
quoi, tu vois. Donc je pars de loin
là-dessus. Euh après bon, je suis
absolument convaincu que si tu si tu
arrêtes pas la croissance, tu si tu si
tu l'inverses pas et que tu descends pas
dans l'autre sens, on arrivera
absolument à rien. Maintenant, c'est
ultra difficile parce qu'on est né dans
un niveau de confort tel que pour nous,
c'était une régression. Il faut accepter
de vivre la régression. Peut-être pour
les nouvelles génération, ça va être
plus simple quoi, tu vois. Mais nous, on
est né avec tout, le robinet, le fait de
bouffer la viande, je veux dire, deux
fois par jour, le fait de, tu vois, le
fait d'avoir des bagnoles, l'électricité
tout le temps, enfin le chauffage, la
climatisation, tu vois. Maintenant,
toutes les bagnoles sont climatisées
quand même, ce qui une aberration, tu
vois. Avant même moi quand j'étais
petit, tu tu suis suais dans la bagnole
et puis c'était très bien. C'était
l'été, tu vois. Maintenant, on a tous la
clime et c'est très dur de Donc moi je
comme beaucoup, je pense que j'ai la
conscience de la décroissance. Je suis
convaincu que c'est ce qu'il faut faire
et j'ai un mal fou à le à le faire. Même
les voyages en avion, tu vois, me dire
qu'il faut que j'arrête de de Là, on a
été à Bali il y a 2 ans, c'était
extraordinaire, c'était un voyage
fabuleux mais j'ai cramé mon bilan
carbone pour je sais pas combien
d'années. Enfin, tu vois, parce qu'on
était quatre à faire un voyage, tu vois.
Et vas-y, renonce à ça, renonce au
voyage, renonce au fait au plaisir et et
et à la bourgeoisie extraordinaire
d'aller voir d'autres pays, d'autres
cultures, d'autres paysages qui est
quand même une liberté fantastique quoi.
Renonce à ça pour la décroissance, tu
vois. Ben moi, je sais que c'est la
chose que j'aurais le plus de mal à
renoncer, c'est d'aller voir les autres
cultures, tu vois. Par exemple, ça c'est
je peux relancer, moi j'ai moins de
viande, il y a plein de choses que je
peux faire. Moi, j'ai pas de voiture,
j'ai pas le permis, j'ai pas de
smartphone, je bouffe pas de météorar et
de terrar. Voilà, je je suis souvent
déconnecté. Bon, mais tu as toujours un
truc qui est ton confort ou ton délire
et là on te dit mais non Alin maintenant
c'est fini, arrête de faire des voyages
intercontinentaux.
Et tu fais vous êtes sûr quand même je
peux pas aller au la hausse ou tu vois.
Donc voilà. Oui, bien sûr la
décroissance mais bon il faut il
faudrait vraiment descendre dans le
lotroissance. Là, j'ai travaille sur une
série télé sur les migrants temporels.
On est en 2004 comme ça et je monte une
société complètement décroissante. C'est
Anthorti qui est devenu une taiga et et
on et j'ai fait tout le tout le système
de de l'univers et sur la décroissance
avec des technos vraiment lot avec on
peut pas accumuler l'énergie, tu vois.
On accccumule pas l'énergie. C'est que
tu as pas le droit d'avoir des piles et
cetera. Si tu veux avoir l'électricité,
tu pédales ou tu tu vois. Et le principe
c'est que à partir de moment où tu
accumules l'énergie, ça commence à être
le bordel et tu vas commencer à à
extraire, à t'arriire, tu vois.
Donc, j'essaie de travailler sur ces
concepts, de les montrer mais pour
l'instant je suis pas un modèle du tout
moi.
Tu as travaillé un peu sur la monnaie ?
Très peu. Je voulais dans les furtifs
travailler sur les sur les voilà sur les
cryptomonnaies. Je voulais travailler
sur les monnaes fictives. J'ai un pote
qui est sur un très beau projet de
monnaie fictive mais j'ai pas encore
développé ça. J'aimerais faire un livre
vraiment sur l'argent sur l'argent comme
vecteur d'échange et que c'est un mais
je l'ai pas fait là. Ouais.
La la clopsologie ça te parle ?
Ouais. Je suis très je suis quand même
critique. Je
j'ai beaucoup de soucis avec au sens où
voilà le diagnostic est super. Euh moi
j'aime beaucoup Pablo Serving, c'est un
gars adorable et je pense très sincère.
Maintenant il arrive à la collapsologie
ce qui s'est passé avec Marx et le
marxisme. C'estàd que ce que les gens
commencent à en faire
et les affects que ça mobilise moi me
paraissent ultra dangereux. Voilà,
c'estàd que je reconnais là c'est le le
groin, tu sais, je reconnais là aussi
des affects très religieux,
apocalyptiques,
une énorme complaisance aussi.
Grou,
pardon,
très gourou.
Ah ben très gourou, le deep, le new
edge, enfin, tu sens tout ça derrière.
Euh et surtout une énorme complaisance,
c'est-à-dire de cette espèce de
fascination de dire tout là, tout va
s'effondrer, tout est dans la merde,
tout va s'effondrer et cetera. C'est
censé provoquer un choc de conscience et
des changements de comportement.
Finalement, ça provoque le fait de se
vautrer dans la complaisance, de dire
"De façon, tu vas s'écrouler en fait."
Et en fait, ce qui va s'écrouler, c'est
le modèle thermodynamique quoi, tu vois.
C'est c'est l'épuisement des énergies
fossiles. C'est ça qui va qui va au bout
d'un moment s'écrouler. Euh donc c'est
le confort petit bourgeois dans lequel
nous on est né et qui suit les tr
glorieuses et dans lequel on spavane,
nous les occidentaux. Parce que quand tu
te parles aux intellectuels africains de
de la collapsologie, ils te disent "Mais
oui, en fait, vous allez vivre comme
nous, quoi." C'est ça votre
collapsologie. Tu vois, c'est là tu fais
Ouais, peut-être
tu vas mourir à 50 ans.
Voilà. Non mais tu vois, c'est-àd que à
un moment donné, oui, on est dans un
dans un système hyper valorisé. On est
plus de la planète nous parce qu'on est
les plus riches de la planète, nous les
occidentaux. Et à un moment donné, quand
on lui dit "Bah les gars, il va falloir
réduire la voilure, on fait "Oh là là,
c'est la catastrophe". Mais donc je
ouais, je suis très critique sur ce
côté. Et après la deuxième chose qui me
gêne moi dans cette forme d'écologie là,
c'est que moi je suis vraiment sur le
vivant. Moi ce qui me passionne, c'est
le vivant.
Je crois profondément la force de
résilience du vivant. Je crois que le
vivant va va s'en sortir à toujours.
C'estàd que
tu tu mets l'homme dedans ou tu mets
Oui ouais. Je mets l'homme aussi dedans
quoi. Tu vois, c'estàd que contrairement
à ce que les gens disent, si le niveau
de confort s'écroule complètement ou si
a les catastrophes naturelles, on le
voit sur tous les catastrophes
naturelles, il y a une solidarité
énorme. C'estàd que les hommes
retrouvent cette capacité d'empathie
qu'on perd parce qu'on est isolé dans
nos petites petites bulles de
technococon, dans notre petit confort
petit bourgeois. Et donc on est, je
dirais l'espèce humaine ou en tout cas
on est on est une modalité de l'espèce
humaine la plus la plus triste et la
plus méprisable au sens où on perd
l'empathie, on perd la solidarité et
cetera, mais parce qu'on n'est pas
confronté à des situations qui génèrent
non plus cette empathie. Donc ce qui
fait qu'on veut surtout pas avoir les
migrants qui créent en Méditerranée, tu
vois. Euh alors que si tout d'un coup on
se tape une catastrophe, tu vois les
cataclysmes en Louisiane ou n'importe
quoi, les séismees, tout d'un coup se
génère une entraide colossale. C'est
l'inverse de ce qu'on raconte. les gens
disent "On va s'entretuer, ça va être
l'horreur, ça va être sur la route, ça
va, tu sais, enfin ça va être la route
de". Non, ça sera l'inverse qu'on va
retrouver de l'empathie, on va retrouver
euh le plaisir d'être ensemble, de se
soutenir réciproquement, de Tu vois, euh
moi je l'ai vu dans le Vercor, tu vois.
J'ai vu 4 ans dans le Vercor
où ça ?
Euh Chapelle en Vercorp, tu vois.
Oh, sérieux ?
Ouais, sérieux.
Il y a un très bon centre équisse
là-bas.
Ouais. Et tout à fait. Et euh et j'ai
découvert, tu vois, en vivant 4 ans
là-bas, la simple impact du climat. Tu
as froid en hiver, il faut du bois et
cetera.
et ben tu as tout un système d'entraide
autour du fait d'avoir chaud, de passer
du bois, de le fait de partager une
situation climatique dure pour tout le
monde, ça crée un truc, ça crée une
empathie, ça crée le partage
d'expérience communes et ça fait que moi
j'ai jamais eu autant de liens sociaux
que là-bas quoi. Tu vois, j'ai gardé
plein de potes du Vercor qui restent des
très bons potes parce qu'il y a une vie
sociale hyper forte liée aussi au fait
bah que climat, il faut se sortir les
doigts, tu dénaiges, tu vas chercher le
bois, tu tu vois et tout de suite ça
crée quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus
sympa que de vivre à Paris dans un
appart manière quoi tu vois. On est
d'accord. Très très jolie.
Ouais.
Euh question internet qui on va la poser
comme ça. Comment il comprend que
l'énergie n'est jamais une question dans
la SF ? Alors je dirais pas jamais mais
pas souvent.
Ah je pense que c'est faux ça. Mais
ouais je pense que c'est tout à fait
faux. Je pense que l'énergie a été un
thème énormément traité. Moi je suis pas
lecteur de SF hein. Je voilà je lis pas
de Tu
as vu Soleil vert ?
Oui j'ai vu Soleil Vert bien sûr.
Br un peu. Ras de Burie.
Ah oui Br quand même tu vois. Mais mais
Rabbur parce que parce que il a un style
politique, ça c'est quand même un des
plus beau bel écrivains en terme
politique de de SF. W Radburry
de deux de Bradbury. Tu en as deux là.
Chronique martienne.
Ah le le le le l'homme illustré. L'homme
illustré. Recueil de nouvelles.
Magnifique.
Et Fen
450.
Ouais Fen mais je j'ai je suis moins
c'est marrant, j'ai moins été je trouve
Fahenheit c'est vraiment un livre
d'écrivain tu vois. C'estd que cette
idée c'est un fantasme d'écrivain
Fahenheit. Cette idée que tu peux
retenir tous les livres par cœur tu
vois. Tu sens vraiment le fantasme
d'écrivain. Je je trouve pas
fondamentalement ça intéressant. C'est
marrant Fahenhe ça m'a jamais trop trop
touché.
Quelle température brûle le papier
451 c'est ça ? Je sais pas comment ça
fait en degré mais tu vois je trouve que
c'est plus un délire d'écrivain. Par
contre par contre l'in ministérie est
très beau. Ouais il y a chronique
martienne et il y a des idées
excellentes dedans. Moi je lis pas de
non honnêtement je lis pas de SF
vraiment je de toute façon je lis très
peu de romans. Je lis vraiment beaucoup
plus de philos sociaux mais pas du tout
de
pas du tout de roman. Je trouve que
c'est moins c'est moins puissant que
lire la philo qui v me donner beaucoup
plus de de bill. Donc non, l'enjeu de
l'énergie, je je j'ai pas de de d'idée
en tête là-dessus mais je je pense qu'il
se trompe. Ouais. sur le
Tu as une blague à nous raconter ? Oh
[__] ! L'autre fois m'en a raconté une
cinquantaine et je ne retiens rien.
C'est horrible quoi. Euh non, j'ai pas
ça.
Ouais, je suis nul là-dessus.
Tu reviendras nous voir pour en parler ?
Ah ouais, bien sûr. Moi je c'est
dommage, on on a pas parlé beaucoup de
littérature, on a parlé beaucoup de
évidemment de de politique, mais bon,
c'est aussi euh c'est aussi un chant
tellement important et c'est aussi pour
ça que j'écris. Euh j'ai j'ai je suis
vraiment entré en littérature pour euh
pour porter effectivement des valeurs
euh politiques, en tout cas une vision
du monde politique. Donc c'est bien
qu'on en parle, mais voilà, j'aurais pu
parler de
de l'art vraiment.
Dis-moi, dis-moi.
Ouais. Non, non, mais on parlera une
autre fois. Je sais pas, je veux pas
saouler les gens mais mais voilà c'est
c'est c'est
quand même un art magnifique la
littérature, on se rend pas compte parce
qu'on va voir beaucoup de films, on voit
beaucoup de séries télé, on joue à des
jeux vidéos, on écoute de la musique et
on oublie que la littérature est quand
même un art pour moi princepte quoi.
C'est-à-dire que la plupart des grandes
séries, des grands films viennent
souvent d'un livre et que c'est un des
rares arts. C'est marrant parce que
c'est le plus sobre de tout. C'est que
tu as tu as juste des petites lettres
noires sur une page blanche. C'est
extrêmement sobre comme c'est presque
désincarné parce que tu to tu vois tu
écoutes de la musique, voilà, des
vibrations
vont se répercuter dans ton corps. Tu tu
regardes un tableau, tu as les couleurs
qui jaillissent et cetera. Donc ça ça
fait appel à des sens directement. la
littérature, tu dis bah c'est vraiment
tellement peu sensuel, tu ouvres un
livre, tu as ses lettres blan c'est un
vrai art du cerveau mais mais cet art du
cerveau passant par le langage fait que
ça restitue toutes les sensations. Ça
fait que tu peux véhiculer énormément
d'affect de d'émotion de de sensualité
par la poésie et par le
donc par le livre, mais aussi des
percepts, c'est des façons de percevoir
le monde que tu que tu avais pas avant.
Et aussi, et ça c'est génial, c'est des
concepts quoi. C'est tu peux porter
quand tu écoutes de la musique, la
musique peut porter des percepts et des
affects mais jamais tu pourras te porter
des concepts. Tu vois, musique peut pas
te raconter les idées quoi. Tu peux pas
te t'amener les idées, te faire
réfléchir. Euh, elle peut te toucher,
elle peut te faire danser, elle peut
t'émouvoir, mais elle t'amènera jamais
cette cette couche là. Or, la
littérature permet tout, quoi. Voilà, il
permet tout. Et c'est un art complet.
Voilà, c'est un art fabulous quand tu
écris parce que ça mobilise la totalité
de ce que tu es. tous tes souvenirs,
toutes tes perceptions, toutes tes
sensations et c'est un art magnifique
quand tu le restitues, quand tu le
donnes et que les gens rentrent et euh
et prouvent voilà la totalité de et moi
j'essaie de voilà de travailler vraiment
sur ces trois couches affect percep
concept tout le temps et que tout le
livre tu tu sois sur ses strates et que
ça et c'est un vrai bonheur voilà de
faire ça et de sortir le livre et voilà
et de l'amener en espérant que les gens
ça touche les gens que ça leur apporte
quelque chose quoi. Que ça leur donne
cette énergie que que j'espère
transmettre voilà
que ça leur fasse prendre un peu le
temps.
Ah ouais. aussi parce que c'est tu sais
c'est une traversée un livre un livre
comme ça c'est ça peut être 15 20 heures
de lecture donc c'est une durée. Ah ben
on va le montrer quand même sinon mon
éditeur il va m'engueuler.
Donc voilà la bête la la brique jaune.
On a on est très on est très voilà gilet
jaune hein sur le je sais pas si je suis
face à la caméra ou
j'aime bien j'ai l'impression de faire
vraiment de la promo pour une fois je le
voilà comme ça. Ah c'est fort. Voilà.
Donc c'est pour moi c'est hyper bizarre
parce que je j'ai terminé il y a très
peu de temps.
Donc toute ta vie là ça duré 14 ans
quand même entre les premiers
15 ans non
ouais 15 ans entre les premiers dans le
cahier la fin et c'estes 3 ans
d'écriture et tout d'un coup ça devient
voilà une petite brique un objet un
produit. C'est un produit
malheureusement aussi euh et tuas et tu
sais que tout est enfermé là-dedans pour
toi quoi. Et et c'est rien tu vois c'est
juste un break quoi. Voilà.
J'aime bien ta façon de tenir.
C'est
c'est un peu ton bébé. Ouais bah tu sais
tu es là tu tu le prends, tu l'ouvres
quand tu l'as et puis tu as tellement de
correction, tu as un tel boulot, les
gens se rendent pas compte hein. C'est
vraiment je crois que c'est un des arts
les plus longs quand tu fais un roman
comme ça. C'est c'est beaucoup plus long
que faire un film par exemple. Tu vois ?
Tu veux lire un passage ?
Ouais. Vous voulez ?
Choisis.
Euh
allez on refire sur la poésie un peu et
mais la poésie politique. Alors on va
faire un passage que j'aime beaucoup.
rigolo. Allez, parce que j'ai pas fait
de blague. Alors, on va faire donc c'est
en plein émeut à Marseille. Donc là, on
a on a justement une hybridation humain
furtif. C'est dans une émeute et c'est
un délire sur le son que. Voilà. Donc,
vous allez entendre, c'est que des
doubles que et donc j'écris l'émeutes
mais avec ce délire sur les doubles queu
produit un effet, ce qu'on appelle
explosive. Ça s'appelle les explosives
sourdes. C'est le son plus le plus
explosif de de la langue en fait. Le
cœur. Voilà. En français hein ?
En français quel kiproco ! Quel quak les
camarades caracolent pour consolider la
barricade qui recule macaque ? Eux ou
nous eux hein ?
Des kamikazes et des cascou tank en
quincon des cano et kayak sur des
camping-car.
Côté mairie, le est un chaos de carcasse
de clic claque craspecalé sur des cris
craft de 44 cubiquassé jusqu'à la
caricature.
Les cancrelas à casque casac kak k kaki,
les pas cardiaques en tout cas sont au
contact de des kékés casac noir parcours
christique qui font claquer leur calico
mars attaque et leur kakono coupé collé
de porcoll
quelques-uns craignant la cacophonie
tiennent cocus à l'écart quelques autres
une kirrielle sous la cataracte continue
des lacrimeaux recule à contre-cœur
tantw qu'un pas de kaboui se décale en
crabe quand il ne cludique pas le genou
en cacahuète ou la clavicule en vrac en
quête du cataplasme d'un street médique
ou du chiropracteur qui d'un cric craque
te remet l'épaule d'un quinka car un kaa
sans que tu que un karaokeé électrofunk
aussi sec mon coco
dans le cocon de leur cockpict de plexie
les pilotes de concept car cor cor
cornaquent leur kraken pour croquer
quiconque court apporter de tentacules
mais pour qui capte le combat ils ont du
cacao dans leur couch Bouche culotte les
mectons. Ça cocotte du coxis la colique
coule sur leur connectique. Je critique
pas quak juste il craque car les
conquisador des barricades en cache-cool
et caric rompus au bivoaclaxonnent tout
à coup leur cocorico et sortent de leur
carqui des cascades de couscous au
curcuma. Des curcubitacés cradoc et
passé du coca collant. De quoi
contrecarrer les robots et
courtcircuiter les criquets qui nous à
la nuque.
Là-bas, au bout du quai, des canacques
tranchent coup les câbles des canons à
sang. Quick ! Tout près les
contreplaqués des vitrines craquent
encore ! Une cavalcade catartique d'un
coup descend la barricade comme la
mitraille calme d'une kalashnikov,
comme une rasade de cognac ou de vodka
servie sur glace. Le bloc des camarades
fonce. 3 2 impact. Le pack des flics
éclate. Les Golgottes bascule plombé par
leur carapace. Leur casque cabossé
roulent sous les pare-chocs. Ricraque
les camarades passent. Il court toujours
compact. Coucou les cocus. Le panier est
à nous.
Alin Damazou.
Voilà.
Merci.
Ben merci beaucoup. Je sais pas combien
de temps on a mis c'est du délire.
1h45.
Ouais, ça va. À la prochaine.
Merci beaucoup. Merci à toi.
Salut.
[Musique]